général
[Musique]
henri bentégeat bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
nous sommes sur une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement présenté
justement voilà je m'appelle henri
bentégeat j'ai 75 ans quinze
petits-enfants c ette j'ai
passé au total plus de 40 ans dans
l'armée française et
j'ai été pour terminer le patron des
armées je puis dire chef d'état major
des armées françaises et
donc sous l'autorité du président de la
république bien sûr et après
avoir terminé dans avec l'armée
française j'ai passé encore trois ans à
bruxelles comme président du comité
militaire de l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire le comité des chefs
d'état-major des pays européens et puis
je suis maintenant comment
dirais-je plus libre de mon temps et de
mes activités et je continue quand même
à travailler un minimum avec les armées
parce que je suis depuis un an vice
président du comité d'éthique de la
défense ce comité d'éthique qui
rattachait directement auprès de la
milice des armes et florence parly est
chargé de donner des avis sur notamment
les questions éthiques posés par les
nouvelles les nouveaux armements le
comment dirais-je d'irruption de
l'intelligence artificielle temps les
systèmes d'armes les problématiques du
soldat augmentée etc voilà nous avons
déjà émis
deux avis
deux avis et nous travaillons sur les
deux avis suivant actuellement voilà à
peu près tout ce que je peux dire si ce
n'est que je
suis enchanté de cette impression de
pouvoir échanger avec vous et bien nous
aussi nous aussi on va commencer
doucement où commence tout de suite en
font que deuxième on peut on peut on
peut dans tous les sens dans tous les
sens bon alors on commence gentiment
alors pourquoi
avoir fait militaire
pourquoi avoir passé 40 ans avec notre
armée on a plein de questions vous posez
en fait et on va commencer par le début
pourquoi militaire pourquoi militaires
auraient coûté contrairement à la
plupart de mes camarades j'ai toujours
voulu être militaire toujours depuis que
j'étais depuis que j'étais seul
et dire presque petit enfant pourquoi je
me suis posé la question quelquefois je
me suis posé la question et la réponse
c'est que d'une
part j'étais né dans une famille qui
était très patriote très attaché à la
france
d'autre part je lisais beaucoup de
livres davanture lesquels alors j'ai
commencé par comme tout le monde si je
puis dire par par l'irs alexandre dumas
jules verne bon et puis je suis passé à
joseph peyré 1 à
quelques autres pour terminer d'ailleurs
les dernières années par julien gracq
qui a écrit à mon avis les deux plus
beaux livres qu'on puisse dire sur la
guerre et en particulier la tente qui
est une part importante de la vie
militaire le rivage des syrtes et et un
balcon en forêt voilà et toutes ces
lectures entretenu
chez moi à la fois le goût de l'aventuré
et le goût du service du service de la
france vous avez vous avez commencé dans
quel corps d'armée alors j'ai commencé
je suis rentrée à saint cyr après avoir
passé le concours
bon selon les procédures habituelles et
puis en sortant de saint cyr j'ai choisi
les
troupes de marine ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les troupes coloniales sir les
troupes qu'ils étaient avant tout
destinées à l'intervention ou à la
présence en afrique bon pour l'essentiel
en afrique en fait dans le vent les ex
colonies françaises et puis à
l'intérieur des troupes de marine où il
ya toutes les spécialités j'ai choisi la
spécialité armes blindés voilà ce qui
fait qu'après après après saint cyr je
suis allé à saumur pour me former aux
techniques de l'armé blindée et puis
après j'ai servi à un peu partout dans
le monde un peu partout j'ai commencé en
allemagne puis je suis parti au sénégal
puis en france plus tard à djibouti puis
en france à nouveau ensuite
aux états unis puis en france puis aux
antilles puis en france puis à bruxelles
pour terminer vous avez plongé à
djibouti à djibouti oui j'ai plongé un
peu oui bien sûr si vous misez sur les
trois frères c'est ça comment ça
s'appelle oui
et non je n'ai pas plongé là j'ai pas
plonger là mais c'est vrai que les fonds
marins de djibouti sont parmi les plus
beaux du monde l'éthique
l'éthique avec le les nouveaux types
d'armements on a appris récemment que un
drone avait engagé un homme sans en
avoir reçu l'ordre qu'est
ce que ça fait d'avoir maintenant des
drones autonome et qui chasse sans avoir
l'autorisation de de thierry chasse avec
le rôle leur propre avis est-ce que ça
va être amené à se généraliser est-ce
que ça va être amené à
alors
ces cétacés cette question en fait de la
robotique dans les systèmes d'armes
cette question de l'intelligence
artificielle qui permet effectivement à
partir d'algorithmes créé par des hommes
il faut jamais l'oublier au départ est
ce que vous dites ces algorithmes
qu'est-ce que qui est ce qui nous dit
c'est un gris et bien et bien est-ce que
c'est précisément une des questions sur
lesquelles le comité d'éthique auquel
j'appartiens s'est penché et pour nous
il est extrêmement important qu'à toutes
les étapes de fabrication de ces de ces
robots si je puis dire en tout cas de ce
système d'armes incluant une part
d'autonomie qu'à toutes les étapes y est
ce qu'on appelle des examens de licéité
cirque on vérifie à toutes les étapes de
la conception et de fabrication et
ensuite de l'emploi que ça
reste que ça reste strictement conforme
au droit international de la guerre
c'est
à dire que ça doit absolument respecter
la discrimination entre combattants et
non combattants
sachant qu'on n'a pas le droit d'ouvrir
le feu sur des populations civiles bien
sûr que ça respecte chaque fois la
proportionnalité de la réponse à
l'attaqué c'est à dire qu'on puisse pas
que
le col et que les que le système d'armes
ne puisse pas décidé d'une frappe
massive alors qu'en réalité il ya eu
seulement quelques escarmouches en face
et proportionnalité et puis vérifier que
en permanence l'homme
puisse prendre le contrôle de la machine
que
l'autonomie ne peut être autorisée que
quand
une appréciation de situation a été
faite par des hommes et
quand
dans un cadre espace temps délimité au
delà duquel tout s'arrête je
veux dire par là que on peut être
contraint de ne pas par des nécessités
opérationnelles de
donner une certaine autonomie aux
machines je pense par exemple à la
défense d'un bateau défense antiaérienne
un bateau peut être attaqué par
plusieurs avions simultanément et ou par
des drones d'ailleurs on parle de plus
en plus des saints de drones qui
arrivant qui arrive qui arrive en
paquets séculière pour attaquer un
bateau par exemple et il est certain que
si on laisse la
défense de ce bateau se faire en manuel
si je puis dire directement
sous le contrôle des humains on ne
pourra jamais arrêté une attaque aussi
rapide aussi nombreuses et donc il faut
absolument donner
aux systèmes d'armes de défense
antiaérienne une certaine autonomie pour
qu'ils puissent juger telle est la cible
la plus dangereuse qu'il faut savoir
qu'il faut détruire en premier et et
enchaînés toute une séquence que jamais
l'homme tout seul ne pourrait ne
pourrait faire coupe vous parliez de
discrimination entre combattants et non
combattants
à l'heure actuelle où les conflits se se
dilue dans la population ou à des
conflits avec des terroristes qui sont
soit déguisé en civil ou qui pourraient
se couler dans dans la masse des civils
comment on fait pour
discriminer un terroriste alors je vais
vous dire moi j'ai un exemple très
simple à vous donner en afghanistan
quand j'étais chef d'état major des
armées en afghanistan les
les talibans avaient pris l'habitude de
se réfugier dans les villages de manière
à éviter d'être frappé par parler par
les avions voilà bombardée par les
avions et le le commandement de l'époque
le commandement américain en particulier
avait
décidé que c'était une menace trop
importantes pour les troupes américaines
et
que donc même quand il y avait des
populations civiles dans les villages on
devait frapper ceux qui tiraient sur les
troupes américaines alors moi j'ai très
vite constater si vous voulez non
seulement
j'allais dire le problème éthique
sérieux que ça posait mais en plus les
conséquences pratiques que c'est arrivé
sur la conduite de la guerre je suis il
est clair il était parfaitement clair en
2d 2005 parfaitement clair que chaque
frappe aérienne de
la coalition sur un village où il y
avait des de la population civile chaque
frappe aérienne qui provoquait les morts
chez les femmes et chez les enfants
éloignés
la population de la coalition et dresser
contre nous finalement de futures
recrues pour les talibans donc j'ai
donné l'ordre à soi aux avions français
qui les engage et la barre l'afghanistan
de n'ouvrir le feu sur des villages où
étaient installées des talibans que si
une équipe de guidage française était à
proximité immédiate du village et
pouvaient certifier que la population
civile avait quitté le village alors
les américains nous avons voulu à mort
pour rien vous cacher parce que à
plusieurs reprises nos avions ont refusé
de participer aux frappes parce qu'il y
avait pas d'élément de guidage français
qui pouvaient certifier qu effectivement
la population civile était parti mais
quelques années plus tard en 2009 j'ai
eu l'occasion d'en parler au nouveau
commandant américain de l'opération
général mcchrystal et général mcchrystal
m'a dit mon la première chose que j'ai
faite en arrivant ça a été d'interdire
les tirs sur le village bon donc il
avait fallu quand même quatre ans aux
américains pour comprendre que c'était
non seulement inadmissible
scandaleux mais en plus de ça totalement
contre-productif je vous pose une
question on peut taquine si
notre système d'armes automatisés ce
fait acquis par une puissance étrangère
ou même une puissance ali et se retourne
contre nous qu'est ce qu'on fait dans le
détruit bien sûr mais on le détruit bien
sûr si on le peut mais ça c'est un
problème dont on est extrêmement
conscient cirque aujourd'hui avec avec
la cyber menaces si je puis dire on sait
très bien que un système numérisé comme
c'est le cas de tous qui contiennent
intelligence artificielle
un système numérisé donc un système
robotique parfaitement être pris
ce contrôle par l'adversaire on le sait
est donc ça veut dire que il doit y
avoir et ça ça fait partie aussi des
règles que nous avons essayé d'établir
pour la conception et la construction de
ces de ses systèmes d'armes il faut
absolument que la cyber menaces soient
détectés le plus vite possible et si on
n'a pas les moyens de l'arrêter d'avoir
un moyen de neutraliser immédiatement le
système d'armes monsieur
sur l'autonomie de ces systèmes d'armes
quand il ya une bavure qu'est-ce qui est
responsable c'est ce manque l'essentiel
c'est celui qui a codé c'est celui qui
n'a pas vérifié où on fait façon 21e
siècle plus personne n'est responsable
alors justement c'est une des questions
fondamentales vous avez absolument
raison est que le comité s'est posée et
donc le les recommandations que nous
avons faites sont
de définir les responsabilités propres à
chaque niveau c'est à dire les
responsabilités du concepteur de
l'industriel si vous voulez au départ
qui a qui va qui va concevoir ce projet
les responsabilités ensuite de ceux qui
l'ont fabriqué de manière à ce qu'on
soit sûr qu'il n'est pas introduit de
bié ou deux qui a pas eu d'erreur si je
puis dire aux deux déviations par
rapport aux à l'examen de licéité et
ensuite les responsabilités des
politiques éventuellement qui ont décidé
l'engagement de ce type de système sur
un théâtre d'opération des chefs
militaires à paris et des utilisateurs
sur le terrain à chaque niveau à chaque
niveau on doit pouvoir dans une enquête
très rapide déterminer qui responsable
et s'est jamais la machine qui est
responsable ça c'est un non sens absolu
il ya toujours une responsabilité
humaine voilà et les principes que nous
avons essayé nous de décrire de manière
technique et puis les tailler simuler
consiste précisément à permettre à
chaque incident de déterminer où sont
les responsabilités
encore une petite question taquine en
termes de souveraineté
si ce système d'armes et opérer et dans
ce système d'armes il ya une pièce
américaine comme
on fait si les américains disent non non
vous utilisez pas votre système
automatique parce qu'il ya un composant
américain qui tombe sous le droit
américain est ce que en fait c'est pas
en fait créé un système d'armes
américains sur notre territoire aux
primes acquises non mais j'ai très bien
compris votre question si vous voulez et
alors nomme évoque des souvenirs très
précis parce que pourriez
vous cacher quand j'étais chef d'état
major j'ai
connu ce problème à propos de nos porte
avions sur nos porte avions il y avait
les seules pièces américaines étaient
les catapultes les catapultes qui
servait à lancer les a lancés les avions
est allé récupérer quand il se posait et
les américains ont décidé en 2003 quand
nous avons non seulement refusé de
participer à la guerre en irak mais en
plus de ça
convaincu nos partenaires au conseil de
sécurité de ne pas donner de feu vert à
l'opération les américains donc on me de
l'embargo sur toutes les pièces
détachées des catapultes alors on s'est
retrouvé comme ça heureusement ça n'a
pas duré très longtemps mais on s'y
retrouver quand même dans une période
qui a duré plus d'un an un an et demi
sans avoir de pièce de rechange pour les
catapultes ce qui veut dire qu'on a on a
été contraint d'utiliser de manière
modérée ces
équipements sur le porte avions donc
dont nous sommes extrêmement confiants
dans les armes et extrêmement conscient
de de 2,7 de ce problème de souveraineté
et le jeu
tient quand même à souligner une chose
c'est que 84
alors je vais pas vous dire de bêtise
peut être entre 94 % et 98 % de nos
armements sont entièrement franco
français donc je veux dire par là que
nous sommes très peu dépendant des
américains contrairement à tous nos
partenaires européens qui ont qui ont
des avions entièrement américain nous
sommes très peu dépendant mais malgré
tout il ya effectivement quelques
quelques équipements importants
d'ailleurs quelques fois comme les
drones comme turbine de nous sous marins
nucléaires comme
les turbines de nous sous marins
nucléaires dans les turbines de sous
marins nucléaires sont très largement
française très largement mais ne veut
pas dire maintenant qu'alstom je crois
honnêtement qui a pas il n'ya pas avec
alstom qui a été vendu ça crée pas des
petits problèmes ont été menés on a
gardé alors je veux dire nous avons des
accords avec des entreprises les
entreprises qui ont été françaises qui
sont européennes par exemple où les
entreprises comme alstom ou d'autres
entreprises avec lesquelles on travaille
quelques fois comme objet etc nous avons
des accords extrêmement précis qui qui
défie qui permettent de
consolider le fait que ces
équipements qui nous sont fournies sont
exclusivement soumis à la loi française
donc je veux dire il ya normalement il
n'y a pas de contestation possible sur
ce qui vient de ces entreprises là pour
les drones reaper c'est complètement
différent les drones qu'on utilise à
l'heure actuelle couramment au mali par
exemple ou au niger sont des drôles
entièrement américain est là clairement
je veux dire si les américains nous
disait profs on arrête tout on sera
obligé arrêtez vous
parler des américains on va faire une
petite parenthèse on va ouvrir une
parenthèse vous
avez suivi cette petite histoire avec le
danemark qui écoutait qui était le kit
est devenu le poste de la haine et ça en
europe et bien sûr vous avez et écoutez
vous en tant que chef d'état major par
la nsa ou eumeu sans doute souhaitions
d'autorité révélée par oui sans doute
joué mais je veux dire c'est la msa et
coûtent tellement de monde que
finalement je veux dire ils sont plutôt
gêné par l'accumulation des informations
que par que que comment dire est ce qu
aider à en concevoir théorie ça c'est
une théorie d'un autre temps oh c'est
pas une fête le fait qu'ils qui stocke
toutes nos conversations avant il
n'avait pas la capacité de l'analyse
ouais maintenant ils ont davantage isolé
un signal bien précis au milieu de ce
bruit c'est l'équivalent de nos oreilles
d'or sur un sous marin ouais qu'est ce
que ça fait quand nous la france son
chef d'état-major son chef d'état major
est
écouté par la nsa quand son président de
la république est écouté par la nsa
quant à nos alliés les
américains passent par un partenaire
européen le danemark pour nous écouter
et écouter nos amis allemands vous en
tant que chef d'état major ça vous a
fait quoi et ça savent ça fait quoi
notre président de la république dans
ton mot ça alors des
réponses à plusieurs étages tout notre
temps oui bien sûr
d'abord dans cette affaire de
renseignement je crois qu'il faut être
d'un cynisme et d'un réalisme absolu
tout
le monde écoute tout le monde tout le
monde écoute tout le monde et je veux
dire il est bien évident que quand les
français en ont l'occasion et les
capacités il écoute également les
américains sur il n'y a pas de mystère
ça a toujours été comme ça bon il écoute
bien d'autres que les américains
essaient les américains sont
certainement pas notre cible prioritaire
mais mais je veux dire devrait qui
sait ce qu'ils les américains devraient
être notre cible prioritaire si
vous voulez c'est encore une question à
mon avis non en juillet par principe
alors en tant que l'ancien chef
militaire je peux dire que on a quand
même intérêt si possible à deviner les
intentions de nos ennemis avant 2 avant
de deviner seul de nos partenaires mais
ça peut être quelquefois intéressant
aussi d'avoir une idée précise de ce que
veulent nos partenaires voilà maintenant
s'attaquer au
système
américain
je veux dire est beaucoup plus compliqué
que de s'attaquer aux systèmes russes ou
turcs ou je ne sais quoi assumer faut
fouetter hier au cinéma le et puis les
dommages sur les dommages sont plus
grave parce que quand quand les
américains se rendent compte qu'ils sont
écoutés quelque part il ya des mesures
de rétorsion qui sont redoutables en
général après et nous ont fait pas ça
c'est que quand vous avez appris que
notre armée quand notre président de la
république a appris qu'il était écouté
je vais vous allez me passer cette
expression mais on a marché encana je
vais vous dire moi je lui ai toujours
dit au président chirac quand j'étais
auprès de lui j'étais pas là on peut
allaiter pendant plus de trois ans et
demi sont le chef de son état-major
particulier et je lui disais en
permanence monsieur le président vous
êtes écouter il
me disait il suffit de le savoir c'est
tout cela n'empêchait pas de ponctuer a
parlé mais il suffit de savoir jeudi
des choses qu'ils ont envie d'entendre
voilà bon ben c'est un peu comme ça
quand j'étais chef d'état-major si vous
voulez je savais que dans les
conversations qui étaient ces petits
d'être écouté j'avais intérêt à dire des
choses que
j'ai envie d'entendre
quand ses traits je me souviens d'être
allé en visite officielle à l'époque
dans un certain nombre de pays qui
n'étaient pas comment dirais je
spécialement connu pour l'heure pour
leur état de droit où leur goût pour la
démocratie en
général j'ai été invité avec ma femme on
avait l'habitude ma femme et moi le soir
en rentrant de 2 comment dirais-je de
dresser les louanges de tout ce qu'on
avait vu entendu il fait et c'est sûr
c'était devenu une espèce de code
automatique et si
on sait qu'on est entendu on parle un
peu différemment le
fait que nos chefs d'entreprise le fait
que notre armée le fait que les élus
soient soit soit entendu comme vous le
dites si bien ça pose des problèmes en
terme de guerre économique vous pensez
pas sur le plan économique ça c'est
certain ça
c'est une sas est absolument certain je
dis rien mais vous savez on n'est pas
chef d'état major ou n'est pas général
des armées ouais bien sûr mais dans le
domaine alors pour le coup de la guerre
économique
à mon sens le
vrai danger quand même le danger et
cyber parce
que parce que les informations les plus
précieuses sont pas des interventions
qu'on échange de téléphone la plupart du
temps ce sont des informations qui
existent dans l'est dans les dossiers et
pour descendre dans les dossiers il faut
effectivement utilisé des moyens cyber
est là et là effectivement alors le
danger redoutable il est redoutable moi
j'ai eu plusieurs fois des entretiens
avec le patron de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité des systèmes d'information si
l'inde 6 voilà c'était poupart c'est ça
oui oui et l'ansea qui est qui et
l'organisme en france qui organise la
cyberdéfense de la défense contre les
intrusions dans
le domaine cyber l'inde
s'y passe
son temps à sensibiliser les chefs
d'entreprise le problème c'est que
autant dans les grandes entreprises on
est maintenant relativement
équipe est bon et attentif autant dans
toutes les pme qui qui qui coûte x ou
sur le socle en particulier l'industrie
de défense en france par exemple dans
les pme c'est beaucoup plus difficile
d'avoir la d'avoir la même les mêmes
moyens techniques et d'avoir la même
rigueur
appliquer tous les jours parce que c'est
tous les jours le problème le problème
c'est ça le problème de du cyber c'est
que on peut jamais relâcher l'attention
c'est en permanence en permanence qu'il
faut être attentif à tout ce qui peut
rentrer
et où le touche pas seulement les virus
et à y faire mais tout ce qui peut
rentrer et dire vous sortir et vous
parliez on va revenir sur six des onze
que c'est un sujet qui est très
intéressant et qui nous touchent à coeur
vous
parliez des mesures de rétorsion
américaine quand ils se rendaient compte
qu'ils étaient écoutés quelles sont les
mesures de rétorsion française et est ce
que la france n'est pas devenue une
puissance de moyenne impuissance qui
sait qu'elle se fait monter mais qu'elle
est imposée elle a pu la capacité de rue
et pour montrer son désaccord alors
si vous voulez rendre un domaine qui est
presque comment dirais-je qui est
presque théorique parce que oui
presque presque théorique pourquoi
pourquoi parce que la
france n'est certainement pas une super
puissance comme les etats unis mais
aujourd'hui par exemple dans la plupart
des domaines elle peut faire jeu égal au
niveau technique en tout cas avec la
chine ou la russie par exemple il ya
vraiment que les états unis qui
continuent d'avoir une avance importante
dans le domaine technologique maintenant
les
enjeux à
part les enjeux économiques qui sont
toujours tient toujours très très
sensible et effectivement qui doivent
être défendue coûte que coûte les
enjeux pour
le reste sont des enjeux politiques qui
sont fugaces la
plupart du temps fugace et donc dans
notre relation avec nos grands
partenaires parce que les américains
mais aussi bien sûr nos amis anglais et
un certain nombre d'autres bons dans
le domaine dans le domaine des écoutes
qui sont plus ou moins ainsi proc
je
pense je pense que
le renseignement français a fait des
progrès considérables ces dix hier anne
est considérable les moyens ont
tellement augmenté d'ailleurs que la
dgse va
bientôt être obligé de déménager bon
parler de la dg souci sa direction
générale des services et se baladent
avec des montres connectés en opex c'est
ça et qui sait numéro 2 qui se fait
remonter jusqu'en bas de chez lui avec
une monde connecté c'est ça alors
écoutez j'ai été sensibilisé un petit
peu ce type de da proche ou pas du tout
parce que quand on a vu qu'il s'était
fait filocher par un journaliste
français ou sein même de notre
territoire je
sais pas s'ils ont fait beaucoup de
progrès je
connais je connais pas l'histoire
précisément un tueur et j'ai jamais j'ai
jamais eu à connaître de près si je puis
dire j'ai jamais servi dans cette maison
là donc je ne la connais que de
l'extérieur prestigieuse maison c'est
une maison qui est assez prestigieux
m'avait tout c'est vrai et qui a équipe
qui a des moyens aujourd'hui qui sont
significatives et nos amis alliés nos
amis et alliés américains en particulier
savent que c'est leur intérêt aussi de
poursuivre la coopération qui existent
entre nos services ils
ont intérêt pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
secteurs géographiques notamment que
nous connaissons mieux que et nous nous
sommes davantage importé que par le
renseignement humain autant que par le
renseignement
comment dirais-je des lic oui voilà on
les écoute si on veut le satellitaire
aux hôtes bon et le jeu et je sais pour
avoir pour avoir servi pendant deux ans
du nid je sais que les américains sont
parfaitement conscients que ça n'est pas
leur intérêt de tout casser avec nous
avec les services de renseignement des
pays occidentaux les mesures de
rétorsion les mesures de rétorsion ça
peut être des mesures économiques ça
peut être deux mais ça peut être
n'importe quoi c'est souvent tous les
domaines bien sûr on
our danemark et le
fait qu'un nos partenaires européens
censés
être dans la même équipe que nous
deviennent
l'obligé des états unis pour parler
d'une façon très diplomate si j'avais
été jacques vergès j'aurais dit la
[__] des américains le
fait que nous nos partenaires soient là
qu'un cheval de troie pour nous écouter
qu'est
ce que ça vous fait vous en tant que
français puis en tant que général sur
feu très triste pour être tout à fait
franc ça me fait très triste après
c'est après ce sont des questions qui
d'une
part sont récurrentes parce que s'ils
voulaient tous
chacun sait depuis toujours que quand
les britanniques eux étaient
dans l'union européenne il
était considéré d'un stand 2k comme
étant le cheval de troie des américains
bon chacun ses votre part que les
relations dans le domaine du
renseignement entre les états unis le
royaume uni le canada la
nouvelle-zélande l'australie les fans
sont des relations extrêmement étroites
et qui est qu'il ne paie qui ne se
partage pas ou peu avec les autres donc
chacun sait que quand réalité une
information qui est connu par un d un
defy vice inévitablement sera diffusé et
repartira dans l'ensemble de leur réseau
sans hiérarchie alors
s'il ya forcément un minimum de
hiérarchie quand même il ya quand même
il ya quand même un maître dans le
système c'est comme à l'otan si vous
voulez quelqu'un m'a tient bon mais oui
c'est normal bon c'est normal c'est
inévitable en tout cas en tout cas c'est
inévitable alors après après sont des
questions qui se règle entre quat'z'yeux
entre chefs d'état et de gouvernement ce
genre de truc et ça et ça se termine
toujours par des promesses et des
engagements et les machins ou alors mais
mais mais mais mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on appelle sera jamais qu'on appelle
trop bien mais de quoi tu joues bien
flûte qu'on empêche maintenant où il
jouait de la fugue d'une part mais
l'autre paraît surtout on n'empêchera
jamais d etat parce que les états sont
totalement égoïste sont des monstres
froids les états on n'empêchera jamais
des états de faire leur coeur de faire
le calcul que leur intérêt national est
effectivement de donner des facilités un
jour par exemple à l'allié américain
pour pouvoir écouter les autres on
n'empêchera jamais parce que l'intérêt
national même au sein de l'union
européenne reste
aujourd'hui une priorité indiscutable
expliqué
que le
l'ambassadeur du danemark en france
n'est pas été convoqué pour se faire
tirer les oreilles là
je peux pas vous dire je veux dire
quelle a été la réponse tactique adoptée
adapté par le président macron et son
équipe j'en sais rien je ne cherchais
pas au courant est ce que c'est parce qu
il ya vous dans les réponses tactiques
est-ce que vous passez parler du fait
qu'il y des choses qui était dit les
sous
le radar pour faire avaler la pilule
georges donne un exemple l'engagement
des forces
du danemark et au mali le fait que le
danemark nous suivent sur une prochaine
décision est-ce
que c'est pas un jeu de deux petites
apothicaires nous c'est lorsque
tout à fait possible ce que vous dites
encore une fois comme vous disais-je
vers la france peut être aussi un
monstre froid et au delà des
indignations se dire tiens à l'intérêt
national
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est de faire un
clash avec le danemark et se brouille
est officiellement avec le danemark ou
d'en profiter pour obtenir la somme des
avantages qui vont nous être utile dans
l'intérêt de la france et les français
gers à la bonne question et après si
j'étais à la place du président macron
c'est certainement là la réaction que
j'aurais voilà je n'envisage pas du tout
je vois sur deux
d'être postulants à de telles fonctions
mais mais il n'empêche que
fondamentalement je veux dire je
crois tente relations il ya une seule
politique qui tienne c'est ce qu'on
appelle la realpolitik c'est à dire le
cynisme le cynisme de l'intérêt national
snowdon
qu'est ce que ça vous ai vu qu sundance
nous deux mais ça m'évoque d'abord
c'est
complexe où les parce que je peux réagir
à la fois comme citoyen comme chef
militaire dans les prix oui et comme
comme citoyen je suis moi j'étais plutôt
heureux qui assure deux choses qui
sortent plutôt heureux que que certaine
duplicité que certaines que
certaines décisions foireuse
apparaissent au grand jour en tant que
citoyen français oui je m'assume en
surrégime quelles décisions foireuse au
jeu j'ai oublié le détail mais enfin je
veux dire des décisions opérationnelles
pour les anciens l'époque ce que sortie
snowdon ou d où des manoeuvres
diplomatiques du banc mais met alors en
tant que chef militaire par contre là je
suis non seulement réticents mais
inquiet parce que la
diffusion de documents secrets
la diffusion générale le document secret
met en danger inévitablement non
seulement le succès de la mission mais
aussi certainement la vie d'un certain
nombre de la vinasse hollande de gens
vous faites main vous confondez pas avec
wikileaks et julian assange oui pour moi
je vais je simplifie a bien sûr pour moi
je simplifie effectivement
dans certains cas content
donne en particulier des noms si vous le
des noms des agents de renseignements
qui sont déployés à l'extérieur qui
s'est greffé ça on les met directement
sait mais personne personne à donner des
noms non non du moins pas directement
cette affaire-là il ya des noms qui sont
tus en sortie est bon dans des
conditions un peu trouble mais mais mais
le le
simple fait de
faire savoir publiquement qu'on connaît
certaines informations mais les services
de l'adversaire en mesure de déterminer
d'où vient leur enseignement en question
je veux dire si par exemple les
les
irakiens mais il n'avait pas les n'ai
pas les moyens nécessaires pour faire
face mais si les irakiens savez
découvrez par exemple que les américains
connaissent et précisément telle ou
telle information dont il pensait
qu'elle était restée complètement
secrète il pouvait assez facilement en
déduire qu'elle était la source et donc
éventuellement régler leur compte aller
à des à des informateurs des américains
en
tant que général désormais
quand vous voyez arts j'ai cité tout à
l'heure les montres connecter des genres
de la dgse en opex quand vous voyez les
américains publient des coordonnées gps
de certains types d'armements sur sur
instagram ou sur d'autres applications
de running comment nous armer 106 libre
sensibilise nono nos forces nos troupes
pour éviter ça pour éviter d'avoir des
installera meuse ou mal d'idées
instagram zoo côte d'ivoire des
instagram e10
beauty des instagram meuse en
afghanistan comment
on fait on va les voir on dirait on
arrête ont confisqué les téléphones
portables on fait quoi c'est
un sujet sur lequel je veux pas
m'étendre beaucoup parce que c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous travaillons en ce
moment
le comité d'éthique voilà on veut du
frein non et donc cela nous avons
commencé à travailler là dessus et il
est bien certain que l'environnement
numérique aujourd'hui des combattants
entraîne
collision une collision parfois
collusion d'ailleurs une collision
inévitable entre les
communications personnelles ou les
échanges personnels par par mail des
combattants avec leur famille leurs amis
et ce terrain et les
opérations militaires de l'autre et avec
un risque évidemment très forte de de
divulgation de projet ou même simplement
virons de bavures mais ça les bavures je
veux dire pour le coup si vous voulez
mon avis la sphère dans la sphère d'abou
ghraïb par exemple je trouve que ça a
été extrêmement
sain que ça sorte voilà je vous dirais
moi c'est une c'est une des choses que
j'ai dit répété à plusieurs reprises à
mes subordonnés notamment aux commandes
théâtre que j'avais à l'époque en
afghanistan en côte d'ivoire ou au liban
ou dans les balkans je leur disais je
leur répéter heureusement
qu'elle eut abou ghraib parce que
désormais vous savez que rien ne sera
jamais caché plus rien ne sera jamais
caché et ça si vous laisse quelque chose
que vous devez répété en permanence à
vos hommes c'est que on ne peut plus se
livrer à des actes interdits criminels
scandaleux en toute impunité c'est plus
possible c'est plus possible et ça c'est
un vrai progrès pour l'humanité qu'est
ce que ça fait d'être engagée aux côtés
d'une puissance qui pratiquent la
torture les
états unis pratiquent la torture water
boarding harcèlement
avec de la musique et
j'en passe et des meilleurs qu'est ce
que ça fait vous d'être
engagée aux côtés d'une puissance qui
torture alors moi je n'ai pas eu ce que
nous on torture d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on
est un petit programme des jours à sion
s'est arrêté là on arrête la brisure et
la torture depuis la descente allemand
totalement prohibés totalement non
seulement prohibé interdite mais je
dirais pour les français par les
français totalement absolument et de
quelques manières que ce soit quelques
formes de torture que ce soit donc sous
traite pas un petit peu non non non non
non pas du tout du tout donc c'est on a
des codes on a non seulement des
règlements mais on a des codes le code
du soldat le code du marin le code de
l'aviateur qui sont qui sont extrêmement
précis dans tous ces domaines est qui et
qui fixe des limites à tout et des
nôtres déduites les limites sont celles
du droit international humanitaire s'il
ya des choses qu'on a le droit ou qu'on
n'a pas le droit de faire et
le et le et donc la torture chez nous
c'est quelque chose de totalement exclue
moi si j'avais je peux vous dire que
j'ai commandé de nos armées pendant
quatre ans je n'ai jamais jamais connu
un seul cas qui serait qui seraient
restés cachés 1
je n'ai pas connu un seul cas de
dévoiement de cette nature j'ai eu une
affaire c'était la ferme à et où nos
soldats ont tué 1 un bandit d'ailleurs
faut être honnête on tuait un bandit de
manière tout à fait illégale et
criminelle ils ont été jugés pour
salaire mais mais mais jamais de cap
torture jamais travaillé
avec des travailler avec des partenaires
qui pratiquent la torture oui c'est un
problème fondamental pour nous c'est un
problème énorme c'est un problème énorme
aujourd'hui
nous sommes engagés aux côtés des
américains comme vous le savez hausse
dans le sahel mais les américains je
peux vous le garantir son dans un rôle
exclusivement d'appui d'appui
renseignements d'appui logistique et
ils n'ont aucune occasion pratique on le
sait et aucune raison concrète de
pratiquer la torture donc sous une
blague nous sommes nous sommes là dans
des conditions tout à fait sereine par
contre ce qui est beaucoup plus délicat
pour nous c'est que les armées
africaines avec lesquels nous combattons
aujourd'hui le djihadisme ont ont
parfois des dérapages terrible et c'est
pas de la torture si vous voulez mais ça
peut être ça peut être des viols des
crimes et c est donc pour nous c'est un
souci permanent constant et l est et
l'est et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous déployons le plus
possible de détachement liaison auprès
d'eux de manière à les mettre en garde
en permanence et à leur dire que toute
exaction risque
d'entraîner notre départ est donc et
donc et donc qu'on les laissera se
débrouiller tout seul je veux dire mais
c'est mais c'est vraiment quelque chose
pour nous aujourd'hui de crucial
d'extrêmement important on obtient des
choses avec la torture pourquoi
torturé nous et pourquoi torture et
d'ailleurs pourquoi torture et ce pour
avoir des renseignements parce qu'on
s'imagine on s'imagine souvent que les
prisonniers qu'on fait on des
informations cruciales cruciale
notamment pour la vie de nos soldats je
vais pas oublier que cela moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire un séminaire
organisé par human rights first donc une
association américaine contre la torture
et j'ai
participé à ce séminaire d'une semaine
avec notamment l'ancien chef du mossad
les services de renseignements
israéliens c'est à dire quelqu'un de
remarquable est ce cet ancien chef du
mossad s'est
battu pied à pied en expliquant que pour
lui la torture restait toujours un moyen
potentiellement utilisables et lui
opposer son éthique à la nôtre 6 pu dire
lui disais dans un pays qui vit à siéger
depuis sa création comme c'est le cas
d'israël
si parce que j'ai refusé de torture et
des terroristes il y a 10 20 30 cents
israéliens hommes femmes et enfants qui
sont tués jamais je pourrais me le
pardonner jamais voilà
et et nous nous les autres militaires
qui participeront à ce à ce séminaire
nous lui répondrons le drame c'est que
dans 80 ou 90 % des cas les
gens qui sont torturés vont mentir pour
faire arrêter la torture et inventer des
choses et donc la plupart des
informations l'immense majorité des
informations gagné par la torture sont
des informations qui sont fausses et qui
vous embarque sur le fausses pistes et
qui aggrave la confusion générale donc
même en terme d' équilibre entre les
morts provoquées
par le terrorisme et l'ignominie la
dégradation humaine que représente la
torture même
en termes d'efficacité pur froide
cynique la torture n'est pas recevable
d'autant que la france torturé c'était
quoi ces méthodes de favorite c'était
deux carrés de sucre une baguette de
pain rassis c'était c'était quoi
c'était plus de la torture psychologique
du genre on disait aux algériens on va
tuer on va te rouler dans une peau de
porc et ensuite on va t'enterrer comme
ça tu iras janot au paradis c'était quoi
nos méthodes préférées honnêtement je
n'en sais trop rien passé à sa relève
maintenant de l'histoire pour être franc
heureusement d'ailleurs non et
heureusement je crois que là une grande
histoire de torture qu'on a arrêté ou
qu'on a pris conscience que c'était
contre-productif voilà on a on a arrêté
parce que parce qu'à un moment les
responsables politiques en portugais le
général de gaulle c'est le général de
gaulle camif un géant
du gold ya mis fin il n'y a mis fin la
fois pour des raisons éthiques et aussi
parce que il avait déjà décidé que toute
manière on irait à l'indépendance de
l'algérie donc que c'était un scandale
inutile
voilà si je puis dire un scandale
inutile mais je
me souviens d'avoir discuté avec des
anciens qui
avaient participé à la bataille d'alger
la bataille d'alger ça dit plus rien
évidemment aujourd'hui un vol génération
même pour moi c'est l'histoire très
ancienne la
bataille d'alger c'était que c'était
quand dans les années 50 6,57 à
l'époque à alger les
indépendantistes oncle fl elle faisait
entre quatre et huit attentats par jour
qui
provoquait la mort de entre 5 et 20
personnes tous les jours alors
essayons simplement d'imaginer ce
que ça serait aujourd'hui
ici à paris on avait entre quatre et
huit attentats par jour sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte on
peut pas se rendre compte en réalité
c'est effarant et et c'est ça qui a
déclenché l'abomination que la torture
c'est ça qui a déclenché cirque on s'est
dit il n'y a qu'une manière c'est de les
faire parler les faire parler pour
savoir où la prochaine bombe a explosé
et s'est élancé sali les mains on a
perdu son âme dans cette affaire-là et
en plus on a perdu évidemment
le soutien de la population duclair
parlons
un peu technique et on en est où avec
notre capacité de projection on est ou
avec nos capacités techniques quand on
voit les russes faire de grandes
démonstrations avec des missiles
hypersonique ou des torpilles
hypersonique quand on voit les chinois
se balader sur les systèmes
informatiques comme à la maison quand on
voit les américains faire la même chose
nous on est encore à tirer des torpilles
avec des petites montre pour
chronométrer quand est-ce que ça va
toucher où on a des torpilles filoguidé
à l'ancienne on n'est pas devenu
simplement une 2000 puissance capable de
faire la guerre à des pays du tiers
monde ou à devenir la le
proxy d'autres puissances non non non
non je crois qu'il faut pas faux pas
surtout pas qu en face de misérabilisme
je retombe pas dans la puissance le
misérabilisme de la puissance je décore
et que vous mais il faut arrêter d'avoir
des lunettes roses ouais ouais les
choses enfin vous avez tout
à fait raison il faut toujours garder et
effectivement il faut toujours garder
une vraie lucidité sur nos capacités
maintenant
on
n'a pas bien le retard technologique
qu'à la france par rapport aux états
unis est un retard un réel c'est vrai
qui
vient du fait que les américains
investissent je sais plus combien 20
fois plus que nous dans dans l'est dans
l'est dans les programmes du futur fait
du renseignement agressif sur nos
capacités techniques ou et
court-circuité certains nos projets on
ne rompt pas trop ça non pas trop non
pas trop le nom mais malgré tout si vous
voulez notre
niveau technologique aujourd'hui nous
permet par exemple d'être ce qu'on
appelle chez nous en jargon militaire
intéropérables avec les américains ça
veut dire que on peut la france est un
des rares pays aujourd'hui dans le monde
qui soit capable de conduire des
opérations combinées avec
américain tout ça pour quoi parce que
nous avons atteint un niveau
technologique qui nous permet de
maintenir le pont de comptes de
maintenir le contact et d'agir
simultanément avec eux voilà si vous
dire que réellement notre niveau
technologique
aujourd'hui est en retard mais pas de
manière décisive est catastrophique par
rapport aux américains et il est plus
que largement au niveau technologique
des russes ou les chinois plus que
largement donc
je veux dire la france se situe la
france n'est pas une superpuissance mais
c'est une puissance moyenne comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est vrai et dans le
domaine militaire la france est quand
même aujourd'hui un des pays les plus
les plus avancées et si je puis dire le
la
base de la défense française ce qu'on
oublie souvent célibataires aux essais
nucléaires scheer et en matière de
dissuasion nucléaire nous sommes
toujours au
top niveau si je puis dire cirque
aujourd'hui il n'existe pas de défense
par exemple antimissile américaine
qu'ils soient qui qui puisse
l'intercepter l'immense
majorité des missiles français pourquoi
parce que ne passe que nos missiles ont
été constamment amélioré et continue de
l'être voilà vous avez parlé des
missiles hyper véloce russe bien sûr ils
sont un peu en avance sur nous là dans
ce domaine mas précis mais nous avons
déjà lancé nous les études sur les
messines hyper véloce et il est déjà
programmée les torpilles père vélo souci
vous pas du tout il
sera par dont les torpilles perversité
période sur les torpilles on est on est
également en train de progresser mais la
considérable et oui si si je peux vous
dominez touché en août sous marin c'est
ça non parce que parce que simplement
parce que alors si on risque n'est pas
le détail exact de tous les programmes
d'armement d'aujourd'hui pour être franc
j'ai j'aurais pu vous répondez vous
répond que ça existait déjà ouais non
bien sûr mais mais ce qu'on est en train
d'étudier maintenant est de mettre au
point ce sont les tempes et intelligente
si elle est une torpille dans lesquels
on rentre une part d'autonomie justement
et qui leur permet de qui leur permet si
je puis dire de faire des tours et des
détours pourra pour atteindre leurs
objectifs bon donc donc si vous voulez
nous n'avons pas de retard décisif
dans
le domaine technologique voilà en
particulier sauf évidemment envisagé
qu'on fasse la guerre contre les états
unis mais c'est pas à l'ordre du jour on
peut pas faire la guerre contre les
états unis ça répond serait vitrifiés
dans la seconde vous
parliez de la dissuasion nucléaire et
cette incapacité intercepter des
missiles tirés ouais c'est ça mais est
ce qu'on est capable d'être sûr d'être
capable de les tirer c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qu'on ne peut pas se faire
court circuiter notre ordre non par des
moyens cyber ou par des moyens humains
je
suis lâché formelle non non l'ordre
éventuelles de tirs ou savez que c'est
quand même une hypothèse très improbable
parce que ça démontrerait que notre
dissuasion n'a pas fonctionné bon circo
n'a pas réussi à faire comprendre à
l'adversaire que il
avait franchi une ligne rouge
infranchissable qui était que nos petits
dés qu'ils mettaient en jeu les
intérêts vitaux de la france c'est à
dire là sa survie bon et si là parce que
s'il avait compris ils l'auraient pas
fait parce qu'à ce moment là les
dommages qui recevrait en retour serait
bien supérieur aux bénéfices qu'ils
auraient à pouvoir éventuellement même
même envahir la france mans le donc donc
donc si vous voulez servait échec de la
dissuasion ci ont donc on était le
président de la république était
contrainte décider et bien tant pis ils
l'ont voulu maintenant tout est fichu
mais mais partira pas seul oui
aujourd'hui
nous avons des systèmes de communication
qui sont totalement redondant et
qui sont absolument intouchable
penser oui quand et comment ils sont
testés ces systèmes redondants méchant
testé en permanence d'ailleurs
les gens quittent est est ce que ces
gens là sont protégés contre des
ingérences extérieures est ce que par
exemple vous quand vous étiez chef
d'état major des armées vous
aviez un suivi médical est ce qu'on
vérifie vérifiaient que vous ne preniez
pas de stupéfiants que vous n'étiez pas
sous anxiolytiques que vous à votre
moral était au beau fixe est ce que on
vérifie cet aspect humain tant sur le
côté renseignements que vous ne soyez
pas approché par des services ou que
vous ne soyez pas l'objet de pressions
d'autres puissances est ce que cette
chaîne de commandement est suffisamment
audités
on peut
le voir de s'épaissir manière je crois
je crois surtout que
chez nous comme chez les autres
d'ailleurs pour être honnête sauf
peut-être dans les régimes totalitaires
effectivement
staline se méfier en permanence de tout
de c2c ses généraux bon il l'a montré
jusqu'au bout et ils jouaient les uns
contre les autres bon on n'en est pas là
parce que parce que la france ait pas un
régime de taille et c'est un régime
d'état de droit qu'on peut pas passer
son temps à surveiller tout le monde
sent sur le plan médical est ce qu a par
exemple est ce que par exemple celui qui
se trimballe avec le football à
des tests sanguins comme un pilote un
pilote pourrait avoir des tests de
stupéfiants est ce qu'il ya un audit de
son moral est ce que s'il est amené à
recevoir des pressions par exemple
imaginez vous que al qaida phase du
renseignement sur notre territoire
depuis des décennies identifie
des postes clés dans notre armée et
fassent pression par l'intermédiaire des
enfants de la grand-mère de la tente
pour que cette chaîne soit vérolé est ce
qu'il ya un système de défense par
rapport à ça j'ai pas sûr pour être
honnête je suis pas sûr mais pas dans la
merde on pourra dire je suis pas sûr
ceci étant le
principe sur lequel nous fonctionnons si
vous voulez c'est
que les responsables politiques ne nomme
des chefs militaires que après les avoir
effectivement auditer de manière
complète alors après une fois qu'ils
sont en fonction ce
genre de surveillance je veux dire
objectivement serait extrêmement
difficile à mettre en place sans tomber
dans un système totalitaire si on peut
pas passer
son temps passe son temps tous les jours
à se demander si fier le thème majeur
est pas devenu fou président
on aurait pu brûler alors le président
de la république beaucoup de gens se
sont posé la question pour donald trump
ou souvenez bon ça alors rien changé le
fait qu'on se pose la question n'a rien
changé il n'y a pas eu d'audit de donald
trump à ma connaissance par exemple la
légende urbaine que notre président de
la république prenais de la cocaïne
depuis des années est
ce que est ce que par exemple ça peut
être un souci oui ça c'est bien bien
évidemment ça peut être un souci dans
l'hypothèse où oui bien sûr bien sûr
alors je ne sais pas personnellement
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de le savoir s'il
existe comment
dirais-je une forme de une forme de
contrôle de santé sur les plus hautes
autorités de l'état je ne le sais pas je
ne suis pas tout à fait sûr que ce
serait pas contraire quand même aux
règles fondamentales des droits de
l'homme si je ne suis pas certain ça
peut faire pisser le président dans un
gobelet ccc contre les doigts de les
droits de l'homme c'est ça je sais la
suspicion qui pose problème sur et si on
entre dans un système de suspicion
systématique
on est très vite dans un état
totalitaire je
suis pas je suis pas très convaincu
qu'on ne gagnerait beaucoup ce que vous
pensez de toutes ces petites hirondelles
chinoises qui vont se marier avec des
marins français prédisent longue c'est
quoi ça s'appelle la technique du seau
de sable en termes de renseignement
s'est classé de l'est c'était long mais
son amoureuse il ya tout ça à la fois où
il a dit des mois c'est à la fois il y
avait bien évidemment toujours toujours
maraîchers connu j'ai connu un chef
d'état major il ya très très longtemps
j'ai connu un shérif terre majeur quand
j'étais jeune qui avait pris comme
maîtresse la femme
de la tâche et défense d'un pays de
l'est ouais alors virer leur part oui
c'est ça c'est peut-être elle qui
trahissaient mais mais mais on a pensé à
l'époque à juste titre que c'était
plutôt une belle espionne et est donc en
a mis fin tout de suite à la faire ça
c'est la crème une surveillance de ce
côté là si vous voyez quand même et oui
un des camps même surveillance une
surveillance en particulier de tous les
responsables politiques et militaires
sahraouis dans
leurs contacts avec avec des agents de
pays plus ou moins hostile bien sûr
alors on en est où de notre capacité à
faire du renseignement plus agressifs
pour
nous protéger plus agressif est ce que
vous trouvez ce que vous trouvez pas que
on est on a une direction du
renseignement militaire un peu plan plan
est
ce que vous trouvez pas que il est très
facile d'infiltrer la drm est
ce que vous trouvez pas un petit peu
qu'on ait un peu pantouflard qu'on s'est
un petit peu relâché non non non
franchement non je crois pas non le
direction du renseignement militaire il
faut bien voir que son rôle c'est
quand même le renseignement militaire
c'est à dire que c'est pas une
c'est pas une
agence qui utilisent des agents déguisés
en comment dirais-je ans l'homme
d'affaires qui fait ça c'est déjà sous
ses seins pour ici la dgse qui fait ça
voilà alors la dgse elle continue à
faire ça je dirais pas qu'elle ait pas
si plan-plan que ça c'est moi je connais
ce qu'on est très bien bernard emié
l'actuel patron de la dgse qui est un
diplomate mais c'est un diplomate de
choc tient qui a été ambassadeur au
liban à une période réalité ambassadeur
en algérie ouvrons d'un petit peu non
non non non c'est
du solide affirme je ne suis pas je suis
pas inquiet de ce côté-là pas inquiet je
pense que je pense que dgse reste très
opérationnelle le
drm ces cibles sont surtout liées à nos
opérations alors
bien sûr elle fait du renseignement
militaire général sur sur ce qui se
passe mais mais toujours dans le cadre
de la légalité la
drm ne se livrent pas des opérations
clandestines comme la dgse question
internet l'armée
devrait elle avoir pour mission de
protéger les entreprises françaises
comme elle comme elle à celle de
protéger le territoire où des citoyens
oui
c'est une bonne question alors les
entreprises françaises on les protège si
je puis dire sur le territoire sur le
territoire national comme tout le reste
à travers l'opération sentinelle par
exemple contre les attentats djihadistes
ou autres on les protège aussi quand
elle travaille pour la défense par par
le service de renseignements spécifiques
qu'on a pour sa s'appelle que mou alors
ça avance ça paie la dpsd direction de
la protection la sûreté de défense chez
plus à changer de nom je connais pas le
nouveau nom mais mais le mais c'est la
même mission toujours celle qui va faire
l'agent ce contrôle effectué aux c'est
ça je joue je me trompe peut-être le
faire je ne s'est pas excusé mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que quand les entreprises
travaillent pour la défense oui elle
bénéficie d'une surveillance et d'une
protection particulière désormais c'est
sur si c'était quoi un coût qui consiste
à qui consiste à vérifier d'abord la
sécurité a conseillé des mesures
particulières 10,6 et saison si elles
sont laissées r et qui consiste
évidemment à intervenir au premier appel
alors
l'intervention
contre la criminalité c'est la police 1
c'est pas nous mémé à intervenir pour
détecter ou sur les failles et et
comment y remédier comment éviter à la
limite avant tout que ça ce que ça
puisse se reproduire voilà et va lui
aussi les dégâts des dégâts sur les
informations qu'ont pu être récupérés
sur sur les risques ça peut présenter
pour notre propre défense donc donc il
ya déjà alors maintenant les entreprises
françaises quand
on est cependant trop interviennent à
l'étranger que les entreprises
françaises sont directement aux
physiquement menacé la
plupart du temps elles font pas appel à
l'armée française l'armée française
intervient évidemment pour les protéger
s'il ya une menace immédiate et on le
sait bon mais mais autrement elles ont
leur propre système de sécurité que
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps organisé
par d'anciens militaires c'est clair
militaires
français l'ancien militaire français je
vous donne un cas de figure vous avez
entendu parler de ces deux bidasses qui
était chargé de faire la protection d'un
camp d'entraînement de la dgse qui ont
viré assassin à la solde d'une loge
francs-maçons un peu givré vous avez
entendu parler des brouillages entendu
par des quels risques c'est un
représente d'avoir
deux personnes chargées de la sécurité
d'un camp d'entraînement de nos espions
qui n'ont pas été suffisamment criblé
pour
éviter ce genre de dérives imaginez
vous imaginez vous au lieu d'avoir été
des barbouzes a2a dessous il avait été
agent d'une autre puissance ou
chargés de faire du renseignement pour
al qaïda comment
ça se fait pas ce que j'entends bien
votre nouveau protocole de sécurité sur
les entreprises françaises sur l'état
français sur la chaîne de commandement
du nucléaire et ainsi de suite
mais quand on voit qu'on n'est même pas
foutu d'avoir
deux gars de confiance surveillants nos
gars qui s'entraîne on peut quand même
se poser des questions quels risques ça
représente ouais c'est honnêtement j'ai
été extrêmement surpris aussi effaré par
cette affaire honnêtement c'est
extrêmement rare
objectivement extrêmement rare et oui
c'est vrai moi j'ai pas eu connaissance
d'autres affaires de cette nature jamais
et le mais ça mais ça arrive ça arrive
ça veut dire simplement que quelque part
le protocole de d'habilitation comme on
dit chez nous le protocole n'a pas été
suivi et donc quelque part quelqu'un a
failli y voilà d'abord je vous dire on
dans toutes les entreprises humaines il
ya des défaillances individuelles et là
ce qui est pose problème
particulièrement chez nous c'est que
dans ces questions de d'habilitation de
sécurité normalement non seulement il
ya un parcours de vérification qui est
appliquée mais en plus il est
normalement revérifier par quelqu'un
d'autre s'il ya une double validation et
visiblement la double validation soit
n'a pas eu lieu soit ce qui sera encore
plus grave a été perverti
par la
mise en place de quelqu'un dans le
système qui kia qui a permis de le faire
foirer je veux dire ça vous la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est de savoir est
ce que dans le processus d'habilitation
il n'y a pas une taupe comme on dit
comme on dit dans l'enseignement l'a
peut-être voilà non mais c'est vrai et
donc tout ça à l'heure actuelle c'est
évidemment en train d'être d'être
moulinet comme on dit et on est en train
de rechercher jusqu'où les
responsabilités vont et et pourquoi il
ya eu cette défaillance est-ce que vous
pensez que nous a remis
nos politiques sont infiltrés par des
puissances étrangères qui nuisent à la
la chaîne de commandement je vais
prendre un exemple quand la france a
à partie du mont armées françaises à
participer à l'élaboration du programme
nucléaire israélien quand le général de
gaulle a dit tout on arrête tout ça ça a
continué quand même derrière est ce que
maintenant au 21e siècle c'est
toujours le cas que d'autres puissances
puisse utiliser nos propres institutions
alors
d'abord d'abord en théorie c'est
toujours possible sur toujours possible
ici encore une fois à partir du moment
où le système repose pas seulement sur
des techniques no 6 sur des hommes les
hommes ont tous des vulnérabilités qu'on
connaît deuxièmement
en ce qui concerne la sphère de dimona
la ii du programme nucléaire israélien
blessure
pour
un ordre du général n'ont pas été
descendue jusqu'aux ben moi alors moi
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour le
général de gaulle un conte citerons pas
m'aimer je veux dire je sais aussi qu'il
était quand même assez complexe comme
personnalité moi je me suis toujours
posé la question de savoir si général
avait pas laissé entendre qu'ils
fermeraient les yeux jusqu'à
un certain degré si les choses
s'arrêtait pas tout de suite je suis moi
je suis à peu près convaincu parce
qu'elle est quand même des restes des
des liens extrêmement forts à l'époque
entre israël
et la france entre les milieux
militaires et scientifiques israéliens
et les milieux militaires et
scientifiques français il y avait des
abris des liens extrêmement forts et ces
liens ont pas pu se défaire et à mon
avis le général de gaulle le savez est
donc le général de gaulle le je
pense a pu laisser entendre qu'ils
fermeraient les yeux sauf si évidemment
le scandale
éclatée où quelqu'un tout s'arrêterait
c'est le chef d'état-major corps est
pris c'est ça ouais par exemple oui
est-ce
que ça arrive un petit peu de des
plus fusible d'être fusible oui vous
savez quand j'étais au comité militaire
de l'union européenne à bruxelles je
m'amusais à compter les chefs d'état
major qui disparaissait plus tôt que
prévu enfin donc c'est arrivé dans les
dents les dans les 27 pays de l'union il
arrive par surprise on apprenait tiens
il a changé ici tu as changé là et je
suis attaché un regard des pour quelle
raison il avait sauté ben
c'était à peu près toujours la même
chose pas toujours il ya eu des cas
rebonds mais les femmes non
non lic mcchrystal à mcchrystal c'est
encore un cas mais certains mais c'était
messi rejoint le cas général mcchrystal
mcchrystal comme le reste c'était quoi
son c'est un jour ou l'autre des
chefs militaires qui
ont mis sur la place publique
le différend qu'ils avaient avec le
président de la république et ça et ça
c'est presque automatique c'est dehors
dans les deux villes il assez sain non
alors vieillesse et encore oui enfin
c'est ça rejoint ce a rejoint un peu
cette affaire-là si vous voulez il
certain que dans
cette affaire de gens lui et dieu ce que
je connais très bien que j'aime beaucoup
pierre de villiers mais mais dans
cette affaire je veux dire je crois
qu'il n'a pas compris
que le président de la république avait
pris cette décision de réduction du
budget du budget des armées et que donc
n'ayant pas cru ou pas voulu croire que
la décision était prise il s'est tu
comment dirais-je emballé non pas devant
la presse d'ailleurs le 2 mai devant la
commission de la défense nationale pour
pour critiquer très violemment cette
décision éventuelle bon évidemment
c'était inacceptable pour le président
de la république que le chef
d'état-major critique une décision qu'il
avait prise et
la faire c'est donc très mal réglés
comme ça comme on le sait dans des
conditions regrettable
mais met fin aux poudres dans les
troupes ça a jeté le trouble un peu oui
oui mais c'est passé c'est complètement
passé à revenir là dessus revenons à
notre ami mais christelle mcchrystal
ce qu'il a fait lui l'invité il a invité
une équipe d'un magazine pour jeunes un
magazine de ses plus quand il s'appelait
un magazine américain en tout cas qui
s'adressait à une population très jeune
et qui était très iconoclaste et pendant
un mois il les a laissés complètement
libres d'aller partout de voir tout ce
qu'ils voulaient aller voir et il les a
même pas briefé un débrief et si je puis
dire quand ils ont terminé leur
reportage il leur a pas demandé de quoi
il allait parler ça et quand c'est sorti
dans la presse il a découvert que les
journalistes avaient notamment noté mot
pour mot toutes les critiques qu'ils
adressaient sens
sans prudence ni même raison peut-être
du
président obama est donc en fait et ils
ont trouvé en première ligne le général
mcchrystal dénonce là comment dirais-je
la mollesse du président obama a dit
avoir retrouvé sa et la kangoo gamme a
vu sa bulle libre le bouchon est quand
même jeté un peu trop loin et il a
rappelé mcchrystal c'est tout bruxelles
des autres états majors qui sautait
c'était donc c'était ça ils avaient pris
position publiquement contre une
décision qu'ils étaient prises par leur
premier ministre leur président
notamment de réductions budgétaires la
plupart du temps c'était ça bien sûr ou
en tant qu'un chef désormais chef d'état
major général
d'armée pardon comment vous jugez notre
intervention en libye notre intervention
en libye bon
très
franchement alors
j'étais pas au courant de tout parce que
j'étais à la retraite déjà mais très
franchement dès le début de cette
opération
moi j'ai été très opposés je ne la
sentait absolument pas pas du tout
pourquoi je la sentais pas parce que
fondamentalement le
but le but de guerre comme disait clause
8 n'était pas clairement définie et ça
si vous voulez moi ça a été mon
obsession quand ces chefs des majors
quand le président chirac décidé à la
fin d'un conseil de défense on va
s'engager là on va s'engager en côte
d'ivoire à s'engager au liban on va
s'engager au congo et c'est une émission
je sais que j'en ai connu beaucoup mon
obsession c'était de lui faire dire de
la manière la plus claire possible
quel est le but qu'est ce que vous
voulez dans quel état vous voulez qu'on
se retrouve une fois que nous aurons
fait notre opération nous on appelle
charge jargon militaire l'état final
recherché voilà première obsession ma
deuxième obsession c'était de fixer les
conditions pour qu'on ait pas pour que
la peau coopération puisse réussir les
conditions de partir les participants
autre que les français s'étaient l'aider
comment dirais-je le cadre espace temps
dans lequel on allait conduire
l'opération et c'est resté un certain
nombre de 2,2 de données dont j'avais
absolument besoin pour qu'on aille pas
la catastrophe voilà donc donc si vous
voulez dans le cas de la libye moi ce
qui me paraissait flagrant dès le début
c'est que on appeler ça une opération
humanitaire mais on ne savait pas
jusqu'où on irait est
ce qu'on ferait une fois que on avait
réglé entre guillemets le problème
humanitaire on n'avait même pas défini
comment le problème humanitaire sera
réglé et voilà donc on est parti dans un
flou absolu le futur qui nous étions
nous a valu pour le coup l'hostilité
renouvelée
des russes on est parti sur une
opération ponctuelle humanitaire pour
arrêter le massacre potentiel de la
population de benghazi par les troupes
de kadhafi
et puis on a terminé par un par un
changement de régime l'élimination de
kadhafi et le chaos généralisé en libye
donc si vous voulez dès le départ il m'a
semblé à moi que les conditions de
lancement de l'opération était parent
était pas satisfaisant car
quand les conditions ne sont pas
satisfaisantes de notre général
des armées en chef chef chef c'est notre
président de la république vous avez
accord avec moi quand
on est un civil comme ça qui n'y connait
rien il essence est bien conseillé on va
il est conseillé notamment par le chef
d'état major des armées et justement
comment il s'appelait à l'époque âgé
à l'époque de la libye oui oh ben non je
veux pas je veux pas je veux pas
accabler mes camarades s'ils voulaient
quitter parce que tout en retenue parce
qu'il faut bien non non mais il faut
bien faut bien voir que la
pression du président de la république
peut
être telle que toute manière même si
vous faites des objections il ya un
moment où vous devez choisir entre soit
bon ok on y va soit je m'en vais moi je
démissionne et je m'en vais et
ça arrive jamais ça nous parce que c'est
un petit peu là ce vieil adage qui
traînent dans certains ministères qui
est il faut jamais faire de vagues pas
de couilles pas d' embrouille ou
continue le ronron quotidien
mais nous on peut pas faire ça nous les
militaires parce que parce que c'est la
vie de nos soldats qui est en jeu si
vous voulez moi
pendant les quatre ans que j'ai ou j'ai
commandé nos armées j'ai eu 30 morts au
combat et et plus de 300 blessés dont
certains se sont foutus la vie quoi bon
et si voulez moi j'étais extrêmement
sensible d'autant plus que je voyais
toutes les familles et j'allais voir les
blessés dans les hôpitaux etc donc je
viens pour moi c'était une réalité mais
et chirac le savez moi
je me souviens par exemple une opération
qu'on a lancé andy
tuerie donc dans l'est du congo le pour
arrêter les massacres bon à la demande
de l'onu mais j'y réponds se présenter
dans des conditions épouvantables et
donc j'ai fixé un centre de conditions
ce fils et moi la seconde de conditions
en dessous au président ses présidents
moi je suis totalement défavorable à
cette opération sauf si tac tac tac et
puis il ya une des conditions qu'on n'a
pas pu réaliser au début je lui avais
dit il faut absolument que des
britanniques soient avec nous il faut
qu'on ait des soldats britanniques même
de manière symbolique pourquoi parce
qu'on se trouvait juste à côté de
l'ouganda et du rwanda et que les
relations de la france avec le rwanda
est est ce que vous savez je veux dire
il y avait des milices rwandaises et
ougandaises qui naviguaient dans la
région chère je voulais pas qu'on se
trouve dans une engagée dans une guerre
contre le rwanda l'ouganda et
le et puis j'ai appris par mon homologue
britannique
quarante huit heures après que il
refusait absolument de participer à
cette opération avec nous parce qu'il
était largement occupé en irak et moi je
suis revenu vers le président chirac et
je lui ai dit monsieur le président dans
ces conditions si on n'a pas les
britanniques je vous demande d'annuler
l'opération et il m'a dit ça ne se
passera pas comme ça il a appelé tony
blair et lui a dit tony y tu dois
impérativement me donner au moins une
compagnie de seul un pour que le drapeau
britannique flotte à côté d'une autre en
ituri voilà et et tony blair a cédé et
on a une autre compagnie anglaise mais
mais si vous voulez moi j'étais
fermement décidé à m'opposer conques
totalement à cette opération
ici et si il fallait démissionner vous y
était un prêt sur wii ça je veux dire
vous savez quand on devient chef de
canton est nommé chef d'état major des
armées en france on a automatiquement
obligatoirement ce que ce que ce que ce
que j'ai ce que j'appelais le complexe
gamelin voilà gamelin s'était gamelin
s'était c'est l'homme qui commandait les
armées française en 1939 1940 c'est le
grand responsable militaire de la
défaite ça fait aucune espèce de doute
jeu viril il a tous les torts dans cette
affaire tous tous dans la préparation de
la guerre et au sud dans la conduite de
la guerre après et le et ça ce complexe
de gamins c'est quelque chose qu'on a
qu'on a très profondément enfin je veux
dire je l'avais moi en tout cas je peux
vous dire et feu et j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois avec mon successeur le
général georgelin qui avait exactement
la même chose que moi faire l'obsession
de se dire est-ce que je porterai un
jour la responsabilité d'une catastrophe
d'une catastrophe nationale voilà et
donc comme on a ça et ben partir
plutôt que partir plutôt que d'être
responsable de quelque chose qui sera
qui risque d'être catastrophique pour la
sécurité des français je pensais pas un
problème combien ça gagne un
chef d'état major comme ça gagnent net
écoute
et à l'époque où à l'époque où j'étais à
l'époque bush des chefs d'états-majors
je gagnais 9000 euros par mois sachant
que un soldat de base un soldat de
deuxième classe de base gagner le smic
donc
vous voyez la différence les échelles
d'échelle des salaires dans l'armée
c'est ça c'est
ça paraît énorme comme différence
c'est beaucoup moins que dans le privé
c'est à dire et c'est même beaucoup
moins que dans la plupart de la fonction
publique où les où les suspens suspens
au ministère des finances par exemple si
vous les inspecteurs généraux des
finances ont des salaires qui sont bien
supérieurs à ceux du chef d'état major
des armées voilà
donc du président de la république ou et
ou même du président de la république
bien sûr c'est vrai c'est vrai donc si
vous voulez voir le directeur de la sncf
florence parly à une baisse de salaire
considérable
elle était un des directeurs de la sncf
n'était pas patron de la sncf a été un
des directeurs et elle a une baisse de
salaire très forte en devenant miss la
défense parmi les armes et donc je veux
dire c'est un système qui n'obéissent
pas des choses à sa place en fait mais
c'est je veux dire le système n'obéit
pas à une logique simple voilà pour
simplifier les choses c'est pour
simplifier les choses ça vous fait
rigoler questions
questions questions et on va pas prendre
les questions internet tout de suite est
ce qu'on vous a proposé de pantoufler et
est-ce qu'on vous a proposé d'aller
bosser à l'étranger chez nous habille
chez nos partenaires est ce qu'il ya un
suivi du chef d'état-major après quand
il est relâché dans la nature a oui
absolument il ya une commission de
déontologie qui se réunit s'il si le
chef d'état major des armées
n'importe quel chef d'état major ou
n'importe quel d'ailleurs officier
général ayant
occupé des fonctions importantes au
ministère s'il part dans le privé
obtient
un boulot en privé la commission de
déontologie se réunit automatiquement et
donne un feu vert ou non c'est pas un
petit peu ça lave plus blanc que blanc
la commission de déontologie quand il ya
une qualité ya des cadres de l'armée qui
vont travailler chez microsoft ils sont
respectés comment ça s'appelle cette
période de ce délai de noyade
et lewis et puis comment ça se met à
jouer mais comme j'ai jamais voulu
travailler là dedans si vous voulez moi
je ne voulais pas travailler là dedans
je voulais même pas travailler dans
l'industrie d'armement française c'est
simple bon voila quand j'ai eu terminé
mon boulot photo j'estime que ma
retraite était bien suffisante et
qu'elle se signale quand même au passage
que la retraite les retraites militaires
plonge
énormément pourquoi parce qu'une grande
partie de notre salaire est constitué de
primes quand vous ai donné ma solde 9000
euros c'était toute prime comprise et le
et donc j'ai perdu toutes les primes
d'un seul coup on passe à la retraite +
20 % au total je me suis retrouvée si
vous voulez avec
à moins de 6000 euros par mois voilà
donc je veux dire il ya quand même une
quand même bon un réajustement qui se
fait donc on peut être tenté de
travailler effectivement quand c'est
quand je suis rentré de bruxelles sera
libre la présidence irak parce que
j'avais gardé avec lui des liens peu
affectif et est la première chose qu'il
m'a demandée c'est bon qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant j'ai répondu
rien monsieur le président et il m'a dit
non commencés à rien mais vous n'êtes
pas lieu donc bon alors moi je vais vous
trouver un poste de conseiller
stratégique dans une grande entreprise
et je lui ai dit monsieur le président
je crois que ma femme ne sera pas
l'accord et il m'a dit il faut que je ne
sois pas d'accord non messieurs
président bon alors passé car il n'a pas
assisté je me suis pas retrouvé que vous
conseiller stratégique d'une grande
entreprise française bien sûr voilà bon
je crois que ça ce sont des questions de
déontologie personnel aussi question
est-ce que ça manque pas un petit peu la
déontologie maintenant 21e siècle il
ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup de généraux
c'est vrai en france qui se reclasse
avec l'accord de la commission de
déontologie dans l'industrie d'armement
françaises ça c'est vrai alors on peut
le voir de deux manières soit considéré
que c'est pas bien parce que il aurait
pu lui mer ou d'une autre cherché à
favoriser cette entreprise quand il
était en fonction mais ça c'est quand
même très très surveillé très très
surveillée soit considéré autrement
considéré que quand ils sont dans des
entreprises d'armement françaises en
réalité ils permettent d'accroître le
lien entre les armées cette industrie
dont on a besoin pour concevoir élaborer
préparer
l'avenir et c'est vrai aussi pour
vous à l'heure actuelle avec toute votre
expérience quels
sont les trois plus grosses mena pour la
france est ce que c'est la menace
climatique est ce que c'est la menace
russe la menace chinoise la menace
américaine la menace djihadiste la
menace économique oui
c'est un peu difficile de vous répondre
globalement parce que je
sors un peu de ma compétence il est là
ma compétence à moi elle et elle est
avant tout militaire et dion geogeo
politique il
ya les
menaces les plus probables qui sont pas
forcément les plus lourdes la
menace immédiate on le sait tous c'est
le djihadisme islamistes et ça on en a
pour un bout de temps en toute franchise
je crois qu'on est là pour un bout de
temps parce que parce que la fin de la
menace jihadiste passe
par une forme de réformes
internes de l'islam bon comme il ya eu
la réforme protestante
en france face à l'église le
donc je crois qu'on a là encore pour
quelques années bon et puis il ya la
menace lourde et
qui dans tout le monde est de plus en
plus conscient maintenant qu'est la
menace climatique gère avec les
conséquences que vous connaissez
d'ailleurs les conséquences
opérationnelles concrètes pratiques géré
par me parmi les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique
il ya en particulier une pression
supplémentaire considérable de
l'immigration venant de venant des pays
qui seront très affectées par le
réchauffement climatique et notamment
l'afrique donc on le sait le donc epide
et puis avec le réchauffement climatique
on a quand même aussi le risque pour
toutes les régions côtières et serra qui
qui va qui va des bouleversements
physiques économiques qui peuvent avoir
des conséquences lourdes dans les
rapports entre les nations et dans l'est
et dans l'est dans les équilibres
économiques et démographiques et qui
sont des facteurs potentiels
supplémentaires de guerre alors moi j'ai
tâché une très grande importance aux 2,6
puis dhien l'immédiat c'est c'est c'est
l'islamisme et le lointain mais qui va
progressivement et de plus en plus ceux
marqués qui est la menace climatique et
puis lien et puis il ya tous bresse la
menace économies telles et les
constantes et elle est lié aussi au
climat comme on qu'on le disait elle
est constante elle
est aggravée évidemment par la pandémie
on le sait on n'a pas parlé de la menace
pandémique aussi celle là tiens elle qui
avait été plus ou moins d'ailleurs
envisagé
par par le dernier livre blanc de la
défense un bon même avant ouais même
avons les mêmes un monde bien sûr on le
sait bon le
et puis les autres menaces alors les
autres menaces se sont tous
et nationalisme qu'on voit émerger de
plus en plus réaffirmé alors qu'ils
avaient presque disparu ses puits dans
le jeu des coalitions auparavant mais
mais finalement le break si tu sais rien
d'autre que la renaissance du
nationalisme britannique l'éruption
trump aux etats-unis c'était bien un
regain de nationalisme
la russie est en plein
d'effervescence assuré liste la chine
elle
est de plus en plus nationaliste on le
voit par tous les moyens je veux dire on
dit quand on dit on a très longtemps dit
que là s'il n'était pas expansionniste
la chine n'est pas expansionniste
peut-être mais n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui
elle trace sa voie par les routes de la
soie elle elle a des prétentions
territoriales de plus en plus manifeste
est de plus en plus revendiquer sur un
certain nombre d'îles au père plus les
îles oui
oui oui donc donc je veux dire la
turquie sa firme affirme son
nationalisme de manière impressionnante
notamment au
karabakh le vis-à-vis de chypre en libye
partout et tout ça s'accompagne de ce
qu'on appelle la
désinhibition de la violence c'est à
dire que longtemps le système
international à fonctionner plus ou
moins bien plutôt pas très bien
quelquefois mais mais en tempérant le
l'usagé de la force entre nations pas
complètement mais en tempérant le nombre
de guerres entre entre nations a
considérablement diminué depuis
20 ans considérablement bon mais malgré
tout aujourd'hui quand on voit agir la
russie en crimée en ukraine quand vous
même ou maintenant au moyen-orient quand
on voit agir la turquie enfin quand on
voit agir la chine de plus en plus on se
rend compte que la violence d état la
violence étatique prenez et
ça je dirais c'est pas une menace de
même nature que la menace islamiste ou
la menace climatique mais mais mais
c'est un facteur préoccupant de
l'évolution des relations
internationales question internet la
défense où l'armée européenne pour
interrogations quelles sont les blocages
les capacités un terreau pérationnel
alors
l'armée européenne ça
ne peut être qu'un aboutissement ça
qu'il faut bien voir ça le problème
c'est que créer une armée européenne où
on met des gens de tous les pays
européens mélanger
c'est quelque chose que cliqué qui
serait techniquement faisable encore que
encore que on voit déjà les difficultés
qu'on a quelque fois pour faire
fonctionner la brigade franco allemande
bon il ya des cultures militaires qui
sont très différentes salles la plus
grosse difficulté finalement c'est
quelquefois pas tellement la langue tout
le monde parlerait anglais vous passez
faire des visions un bon français ouais
enfin plutôt que français oui c'est sûr
mais mais le met mais c'est davantage
une question de culture mais mais mais
mais à quoi ça sert d'avoir une armée si
on n'a pas de gouvernement européens je
crois que c'est ça il faut pas mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs le on n'a pas
aujourd'hui de politique étrangère et de
défense commune en europe on a quelque
chose qu'on appelle comme ça qu'est la
politique de sécurité et de défense
commune voilà à chanter mais tout ça
mais elle est en chantier et elle est
toujours en chantier et il y restera
longtemps encore bon mais je suis pas du
tout entier européen au contraire j'ai
passé trois ans à bruxelles je me suis
battue en permanence pour essayer de
construire ce qu'on appelle l'europe de
la défense mais faut être totalement
réaliste tant qu'on n'est pas capable
d'avoir une seule politique étrangère à
quoi ça sert d'avoir une armée on pourra
jamais langage et puisqu'on n'est pas
d'accord entre nous on
n'a pas du tout par exemple dans notre
pays européens les mêmes centres
d'intérêt géré les pays baltes et la
pologne sont totalement fasciné par ce
qui se passe à l'est bien sûr et on les
comprend d'ailleurs bon et mais par
contre les pays du sud eux sont
totalement fasciné par ce qui se passe
en afrique et au moyen-orient si on n'a
pas les mêmes centres d'intérêt et on
n'a pas souvent
la malle attitude par rapport au
problème israélo-palestinien par exemple
il ya des divergences très forte entre
les pays européens y a pas de politique
commune pas du tout donc je crois qu'il
faut construire les choses petit à petit
il ya des choses qu'on peut faire ton
tuellement ensemble sans avoir besoin
d'une armée européenne par exemple au
mali actuellement il ya une
une force européenne fois une force un
détachement européen était chargée de
former les
armées maliennes de les instruire de les
former de les préparer au combat terrain
voilà et là c'est pas une armée
européenne qui est là bas où un beau
morceau d'armée européenne non c'est
c'est une opération qui a été décidé par
l'union européenne et pour laquelle on a
demandé des volontaires aux différents
pays voilà et là ça peut marcher donc on
n'a pas nécessairement besoin d'une
armée européenne permanente qu'il
fonctionnerait pas et qui est qui ne
servir à rien qui écoutera c'est cher
mais on a besoin par contre d'être
capable d'agir ensemble
quand on arrive à se mettre d'accord
quand
on voit la dislocation géopolitique
mondiale et spécialement européenne par
cet événement exotiques qui n'a pas été
fédérateur qui étaient là qu'ovide le
coc vide quand on s'est mis à taper
dessus pour avoir des masques sur le
tarmac des aéroports
c'est
révélateur de tout ça c'est on ne pourra
jamais avoir d'armée européenne parce
qu'on n'était même pas capable de centre
était quand la pandémie arrive et quand
on est sous le feu le
militaire qu est-ce qui fait il serre
les coudes vous
comprenez ma question oui je comprends
très bien votre question je comprends
alors bon je veux dire quand même ça a
fini par s'arranger mais mais mais c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui clairement les 27
pays de l'union se
considère d'abord et avant tout comme
des nations comme des nations
indépendantes et le réflexe de
solidarité européenne ne vient qu'après
et
donc quand quand il ya une situation de
crise comme c'est le cas dans temps de
pandémie la tendance est naturellement à
se replier d'abord sur son espace
national à fermer les frontières et
c'est tout ce qu'on a vu ce qu'on a vu
concrètement et après seulement quand on
réfléchit quand on parle ensemble quand
la commission fait des propositions on
se rend compte qu'on a intérêt à prendre
le problème de manière solidaire tous
ensemble et qu'on y gagnera
en efficacité alors on l'a pas démontré
de manière évidente puisque par exemple
pour la vaccination on sait que la
grande bretagne en réalité est allé plus
vite que nous bon c'est clair ouais mais
mais mais donc donc donc la
vraie question derrière tout ça c'est
une question à laquelle moi j'ai jamais
pu obtenir de réponse claire chez les
politiques français en tout cas c est ce
qu on veut ou pas une europe fédérale
avec un gouvernement fédéral
ça c'est la vraie question et cette
question là si vous la pose y est aux
allemands il ya vingt ans les allemands
vous disais oui oui oui on sait ce qu'on
veut si vous leur posez la question
aujourd'hui ils vous répondront non ce
que ce que j'ai tendance à constater
personnellement c'est que l'idée d'une
europe fédérale à la manière des
fonctionnaires la manière des états unis
d'amérique est
une idée qui est plutôt en recul à
l'heure actuelle alors paradoxalement le
président et le gouvernement français
sont aujourd'hui beaucoup plus favorable
à une europe fédérale qu'il l'était il
ya 20 ans mais mais mais si vous allez
regarder dans les pays d'europe de l'est
vous verrez que c'est une idée qui
aujourd'hui est totalement exclue donc
est-ce
qu'on va ou non vers une europe
définitivement unis personnellement j'en
sais rien je n'en sais rien est ce qu'il
faut le souhaiter c'est une affaire
individuelle chacun chacun peut il
y a des avantages énormes envisager une
rampe une europe puissance est puissante
mais
mais mais est ce possible à 27 pays je
ne le sais pas vous
êtes grand fan de carl von clausewitz
vous
avez lu oui c'est vrai vous avez lu je
suppose je présume de la guerre oui bien
sûr qu'est ce que notre petit carlito
disait sur la politique et la guerre
mobilisé la
guerre c'est l'extension de la politique
c'est la continuation de la politique
par d'autres moyens exactement vous
avez confiance de nos politiques pour
aller faire la guerre mais
[Musique]
c'est assez fondamentale vous souvenez
peut-être que en 1988 il
ya une élection présidentielle et que 50
20 45 ou 50 je me souviens plus généraux
ont sorti un manifeste disant
que s'il y avait une menace vitale sur
la france il faisait pas confiance au
président mitterrand pour déclencher le
feu nucléaire c'était un appel à voter
chirac le bon c'était une intrusion dans
la politique qui était scandaleuse
honnêtement scandaleuse et inacceptable
et en plus c'était faux parce que moi
j'ai passé deux ans à l'état major
particulier de françois mitterrand et je
veux dire pour avoir assisté
un à une vingtaine de conseil de défense
qui même plus de conseil de défense
qu'il a présidée je peux vous assurer
que je suis absolument certain que
françois mitterrand aurait décidé
sans sans aucune hésitation donc
donc moi j'ai connu mitterrand g que les
chirac l'un et l'autre à effet la guerre
il savait ce qu'était sont
les mets forcément d'ailleurs mais mais
il savait c'était après
on est entré dans une dans une ère
nouvelle
c'est à dire de président de la
république qui
ne keane qu'il n'avait jamais fait la
guerre le premier c'est le président
sarkozy mais
maintenant on a franchi encore un
échelon supplémentaire sire que sarkozy
et hollande avait fait un service
militaire bon plus sérieux pour hollande
que pour sarkozy d'ailleurs pour être
honnête mais mais mais mais
il savait un peu c'était l'armée
aujourd'hui
on a un président de la république et ce
sera pareil pour ses successeurs pas se
faire d'illusions après dans la
république qui non seulement n'a jamais
fait la guerre il
ne la connais pas mais en plus sauf de
manière intellectuelle bien sûr et qui
en plus de ça ne connaît ne connaissez
pas ce matin il connaît pas mal ne
connaissez absolument pas l'armée voilà
et est donc est-ce qu'on peut a priori
faire confiance un chef d'état qui n'a
aucune idée de ce qu'est la guerre ça
la vraie question et
la réponse à mon avis c'est une c'est
une c sont des cas d'espèce c'est dire
qu'il y en a certains qui ont
naturellement l'autorité et le
discernement qui leur permet
effectivement d'affronter les situations
paroxystique com com com comme le sont
les cas de guerre et d'autres qui n'ont
pas cette capacité j'ai
écrit
un livre il ya il ya trois ans chef
d'état en guerre qui précisément étudier
comment se comporter comment
se sont comportés dans l'histoire
installons des chefs d'état qui avaient
ou non l'expérience de la guerre moi si
vous prenez quelqu'un comme lincoln par
exemple qui n'a jamais fait la guerre
vue qu'avait fait qu'ils avaient
vaguement appartenu à une milice mais
comme il le dit c'est ses seuls ennemis
de l'époque c'était les moustiques
lincoln
a été après
une période d'adaptation
un grand chef de guerre quand
vous expliquer la
tribune des militaires où il pointe du
doigt la déliquescence de notre pays une
un
affaiblissement nos institutions une
pour résumer trivialement ça va pas très
bien comment vous expliquez que ça
puisse regrouper autant de signatures
aussi rapidement je
veux dire pour
pompes pour moi pour moi c'est
relativement simple d'abord
le
fait qu' il
ya une certaine frustration chez
chez les ch et les officiers surtout
chez le généraux d'avoir
toujours du brie des brides et leurs
expressions son canton tant qu'ils
étaient en service c'est qu'on peut le
trouver un peu chez les ambassadeurs
aussi sévère que le devoir de réserve
qui est imposé aux militaires est un
devoir de réserve qui est très exigeant
il ya beaucoup de choses dont ils
peuvent pas parler et
est en tout cas ils peuvent pas
s'opposer en aucun cas aux choix faits
par le par le président le gouvernement
et donc quand ils arrivent à la retraite
d'un seul coup ils se disent à tort d'un
seul coup ils se disent bon ben j'ai
regagné ma liberté je peux dire ce que
je pense donc ça c'est pour les facteurs
le facteur des frustrés qui ce petit jeu
des foules le deuxième facteur c'est
quoi c'est que malheureusement ces gens
qui ont vécu une manière très apolitique
pendant toute leur carrière parce qu'on
fait pas de politique entre les
militaires non
il faut pas être encarté pour pouvoir
aller un peu à gauche et à droite on se
passer nous pas chez nous je peux vous
dire c'est bien la meilleure preuve
d'ailleurs c'est que moi j'ai servi
successivement à l'elysée avec françois
mitterrand avec jacques chirac le don
ont fait pas de politique chez nous
quand les militaires et même je dirais
pour avoir vécu longtemps dans les
popotes c'est les sujets qu'on évite
systématiquement on a en a comment
dirais-je par principe une certaine
distanciation vis-à-vis de la vie
politique mais alors après quand on est
à la retraite naturellement on
s'intéresse on peut s'intéresser aux
affaires de la nation et à ce moment là
on est vulnérable on est vulnérable
on est vulnérable aux gens qui vous font
découvrir enfin la lune et ses
politiques alors ce sont des politiques
la plupart du temps et bien sûr les
politiques qui se servent de militaires
politisé parce qu'anna et alain dans la
sphère du manifeste des généraux a
clairement je dis rien à l'ancien
capitaine de gendarmerie qui qui avait
quitté très tôt l'armée qui apprennent
avec de la politique qu'il
écoutait replacer l'extrême droite
insulaire site est clair et c'est ce
type là qui a concocté se manifeste et
qui a fait signer des généraux
à la retraite il en a trouvé je sais
plus combien ai dis
souvent je sais plus une infime
proportion j'avais calculé je crois que
ça représente 1 % des généraux à la
retraite dont qui ont signé ce truc là
ça veut dire que 99 % n'ont pas signé
bon une certaine manière le mais faut
quand même rétablir si vous la vérité
des chiffres mais parce que les français
ont pu avoir l'impression qu'ils avaient
un groupe très important dans l'armée
qui brusquement endosser
des thèses du rassemblement national
alors non fuir la faute qu'ils ont
commise c'est
de mettre leur grade à côté de leur nom
parce que ces gens là du coup donné
à ce texte une forme d'autorité
militaire si je puis dire qui n'a
absolument pas c'est une analyse
sociopolitique qu'on trouve dans ce
texte qu'on approuve ou qu'on approuve
pas peu importe peu importe la limite
mais en tout cas c'est une affaire
qu'ils auraient pu signer à titre
personnel mais
pas en se regroupant et pas en se
regroupant et ans et en faisant valoir
leur titre militaire voilà celle à qui
la faute parce que clairement ce texte
de nature politique première mort et
donc et donc il ne pouvait pas si avec
leur graal il ne pouvait pas se
regrouper en plus pour signer sa donc
est ce que c'est un fou de vérité un
fond de vérité oh bah je voulais oui il
ya forcément un fond de vérité pour tout
le monde le sait bien mais il ya des
mots qui sont inacceptables dans ce
texte par exemple quand on parle des
hordes de jeunes venus des banlieues je
veux dire mais je peux vous dire que moi
j'étais scandalisé moi je me suis occupé
de classe de jeunes en seine saint denis
pour leur présenter les armes et la
défense etc
je veux dire je suis pourri verrier
conduite sont horrifiés qu'on puisse
fois vous avez fait ça je peux pas pas
beaucoup d'eau trois fois mais j'ai
refusé à midi pour être en santé avec
des professeur es et pourrait pour être
horrifié qu'on puisse présenter les
choses comme ça et ceux de l'opération
sentinelle qui sont amenés à se faire
caillasser emmerder cracher dessus par
exemple j'ai
la chance d'avoir des copains
légionnaires qui
sont fait prendre à partie châtelet les
halles à 2 heures du matin par des
gardes et des gamins qui le crash et qui
savait pas qu'il fallait pas cracher sur
les légionnaires savez pourquoi je
vous dirai pas pourquoi est
ce que l'opération sentinelles a permis
aux militaires du rang de prendre la
température du pays et de se rendre
compte que quand même il y avait des
gros problèmes de violence des groupes
problème de bon
peut-être peut-être peut-être mais il
faut pas oublier une chose quand même
c'est que dans nos armées dans nos
armées aujourd'hui ne
recrutons beaucoup dans les banlieues
parmi
nos soldats il y en a beaucoup qui
mènera mois parmi tous les tous les
morts et blessés cris en afghanistan
côte d'ivoire et ailleurs il
y avait beaucoup de jeunes d'origine
algérienne ou marocaine peut que banksy
tient dans leur milieu est ce c'est ça
oui je veux dire ces
jeunes là ils savent ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les
banlieues où effectivement on le sait
tout le monde le sait je veux dire tout
le monde le dit et pas seulement à
l'extrême droite c'est vrai comme ils
s'appellent jeu colombes quand il est
parti à est reparti à lyon l'ancien
ministre intérieur disait que un jour ou
l'autre on aurait des affrontement
terrible bon donc si vous voulez j'ai
pas aimé moi le choix de certains mots
comme je vous dis se trouve inacceptable
qu'on parle de jeunes français en
évoquant des hordes de jeunes c'est que
c'est pas acceptable pour moi c'est pas
acceptable et et deuxièmement
prévoir comme ils l'annoncent dans ce
texte l'engagement des armées françaises
dans les banlieues pourrais tu pourrais
pourquoi pour rétablir l'ordre je veux
dire là c'est également pour moi quelque
chose de plus que discutable je peux
vous dire qu'en qu'en 2005 quand on a eu
des émeutes dans l'est dans les
banlieues on a déclaré l'état d'urgence
en france et la
première chose que j'ai dit au président
chirac je lui ai dit monsieur le
président je vous préviens je préfère
vous prévenir honnêtement j'ai pas dit
ça comme ça mais je préfère vous préfère
non je souhaitais plus polie que ça
c'est présent je vais vous dire
simplement que si vous
décider d'engager nos armées pour
rétablir l'ordre dans les banlieues je
démissionnerai et
il m'a répondu mon
général ne monte pas sur vos grands
chevaux les
armées ne seront pas engagés dans les
banlieues terminé donc si vous voulez
quand dans ce manifeste ses généraux
vois pas ce qu'il n'appelle pas
n'appelle même pas à ça dans le
manifeste mais il voit déjà nos armes et
faire la guerre dans les banlieues
chérissons dans un monde
à mon avis alors fantasmatique et c'est
angoissant alors il n'y a pas que qu'est
l'extrême droite qu'on demande
l'engagement désormais dans les
banlieues ou l'avais su je veux dire il
ya des élus de gauche qui l'on demandait
aussi dans certaines villes mais je vous
crois que là on se trompe complètement
compétents des femmes à ce n'est pas
fait pour le combat urbain mais ici en
effet pour le combat urbain absolument
mais pas le combat urbain contre les
français certainement pas je veux dire
c'est
pas la même chose de tirer sur des
jeunes français que je tirais sur des
jeunes comment dirais je je sais pas moi
chinois ou russes ou n'importe quoi
c'est pas la même chose oui
et puis et puis d'autre part employé
les armées dans
du maintien de l'ordre musclée on sait
ce que ça a donné en algérie on sait ce
que ça a donné contre les vignerons du
midi compte quand on l'a fait avant là
c'était quand c'était avant la première
guerre mondiale où est bon là on la
refait encore en 47 à ma connaissance ça
s'est très mal passé le les armées sont
pas fait pour ça elles sont pas fait
pour ça est-ce que vous avez vu l'
enquête de mediapart sur
les
militaires français néo nazis se tatouer
avec des devises waffen ss se faisant
des saluts hitlériens se
postant des choses à
la gloire du reich des choses comme ça
est ce que de votre temps il y avait une
radicalisation extrême
n'ont
jamais j'ai personnellement dans l'est
dans les quatre ans où j'ai été en poche
je n'ai jamais entendu parler choses
comme ça mais absolument jamais et
nôtres de notre direction de protection
et de sécurité défense est extrêmement
attentif partout à tout ça elles sont
attentives bon qui est des cas ponctuels
alors je sais pas où mediapart a trouvé
son truc hein
trouver une bonne poignée quand même
ouais bon moi
je mets par d'autres je connais pas mais
par deux collègues qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est de ces éléments là
il faudrait les virait à grand coup de
pied au cul e-mails military faudra les
faire incarcérer il faudrait surveiller
il faudrait faire quoi s'ils sont pas
viré parce que soi disant ils sont
indispensables à leur bataille ou
bonbons beaubois ça j'y crois pas une
seconde alors si c'est l'argument qu'on
a donné à mediapart alors c'est le crois
pas une seconde la première chose à
faire si vous voulez comme s'agit de
faits de cette nature c'est une enquête
judiciaire et
donc et ça doit passer devant la justice
parce que c'est parce que c'est
totalement interdit par la loi et
deuxièmement ces gens là on s'en sépare
tout de suite bien sûr alors
ça il ya eu des cas comme ça dans
l'armée allemande ça veut pas dire pour
autant que l'armée allemande et une
armée faciste je crois pas une seconde
c'est plutôt une heure mais aujourd'hui
qui ne se bat pas normalement les qui ne
veut pas se battre mais mais le met dans
l'armée française moi j'ai jamais
entendu de cas comme ça jamais et j'aime
être même vous avez entendu parler dans
toute ma carrière jamais l'histoire de
deux mouvements face et de mouvements
nazis ou néo nazis dans l'armée
française je n'ai jamais jamais eu de
que connut d'exemple cette épure
question
internet que pense-t-il de l'opération
sentinelle son utilité son impact sur
l'art met alors
en
branle opération sentinel elle
est inévitable premièrement et
deuxièmement elle est là des
conséquences lourdes pour les armées
premièrement
elle est inévitable pourquoi parce que
quand il ya des attentats dans la rue
quand
la police n'arrive pas à les prévenir et
dieu sait quelle on prévient beaucoup
n'arrivent pas à les prévenir il ya un
moment où le gouvernement inévitablement
mais tous les moyens à sa disposition
pour essayer de protéger les français
dans l'insécurité quotidienne et donc
inévitablement les armées et ça je veux
dire
c'est incontournable n'importe quel
gouvernement le fera n'importe quel
gouvernement deuxièmement
ça a des conséquences quand même très
dommageable pour notre armée si vous
rendez compte que on maintient en
permanence sur le territoire national
pour l'opération sentinelle entre 7000
et 10000 hommes total
de coups bien sûr une force total alors
ça
l'epr c'est presque uniquement l'armée
de terre l'armée de terre aujourd'hui ça
représente 120 mille hommes bon ça
paraît rien 7000
hommes ou même dix mille hommes sur 120
milles mais mais la partie projetable
enfin mais il faut y rajouter toutes nos
interventions extérieures c'est à dire
que c'est
7000 plus
bon
je
suis mise à peu près ça fait donc quinze
mille 15 milles en permanence quinze
mille en permanence ça veut dire ça veut
dire que dans les régiments de combat
qui sont ceux qui sont concernés par ces
missions là parce qu'on peut pas y
mettre des gens qui n'ont aucune
expérience du combat et on l'a bien vu
chaque fois qu'une de patrouille a été
attaquée par des par des djihadistes
chaque fois les choses se sont passées
de manière claire et nette parce que
c'étaient des gens de métier c'est à
dire il n'y a pas eu de tirs dans la
foule il n'y a pas eu de ya pas eu de
bavure les choses sont toujours pas ses
manières car elle parce que nos gens
sont parce que nos gens sont maîtrisées
sont capables de maîtriser leur violence
eh
ben ça arrive à quoi il suffit d'aller
dans les régiments pour se rendre compte
ça arrive à avoir des jeunes qui
sont en dehors de chez eux soit
sentinelles sont en opération pendant
sept mois ou une mois par an et ça c'est
intenable c'est intenable est ce que le
politique a peur de ces militaires n'ont
entendu
cette histoire qui n'est peut-être
qu'une légende
qu'on enlevait les percuteurs de nos
militaires quand il y avait des
manifestations avec des politiques alors
je vais vous dire je veux confirmer tout
à fait ce que vous me dites quand
j'ai été enlevé le percuteur pas du tout
mais quand j'étais quand j'étais sa
syrien et
que nous et que nous allions défilé
devant le général de gros loupé le
général de gaulle venait nous voir nous
visiter à saint cyr qui l'a fait deux
fois à chaque fois on nous faisait
enlever les percuteurs de nos fusils
donc
vous dire que c'était un souci très très
anciens bon évidemment jeu pour le
général de gaulle il y avait il y avait
des raisons objectives parce que parce
qu'il y avait eu l'attentât du
petit-clamart donc qui avait été conduit
non fois par des militaires ou en tout
cas des gens de la défense et le donc
c'est un souci qui est très ancien
qu'aujourd'hui
on le fasse je personnellement j'ai
jamais d'oser ce genre d'ordre jamais je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de
situations qu'il suffit très franchement
je crois pas même qui est du tout de
situations qu'ils justifient question
internet que pense-t-il de la place de
la question militaire et géopolitique
dont le système éducatif français
la jeunesse vittel dans un monde des
bisounours entre parenthèses étudiant de
23 ans dans une école d'ingénieurs ont
visage et de travailler dans l'armement
devient très tabou dans ce milieu et
un problème c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème très ancien mais qui est
toujours vrai entre entre l'université
et désarmés est un problème il y a un
dans l'université française un
courant anti militariste ou pacifistes
très fort très fort qui fait que le
dialogue entre l'université et le monde
de la défense était un dialogue
difficile par avec tout le monde le sait
il ya des universitaire remarquable qui
connaissent extrêmement bien la défense
moi j'en connais ce que les historiens
qu'ils ont mais mais mais même ces gens
là ces universités rare qu'ils
connaissent très bien la défense sont
généralement mal perçue dans
l'université et
souhaits souvent tenu un peu les cartes
donc il donc il ya encore ce problème là
s'il peut paraître curieux parce que si
vous voulez ce problème est largement
mené des guerres coloniales de
l'indochine et de l'algérie et c'est là
que la césure c'est fait mais
je veux dire les guerres coloniales
c'est fini quand même depuis 1962 cher
donc donc on pourrait penser que depuis
les choses se sont accommodés mais non
il ya une tradition universitaire
antimilitariste et pacifiste qui est
restée forte et qui fait que et qui ce
que d'une manière générale travailler
avec la défense où travaillent et même
quelquefois sur des questions de défense
est considéré comme une forme de
compromission avec le milieu militaire
voilà et ça moi je le déplore tout à
fait un à tous égards je suis même
frappé sous les pas par le fait que à
l'école nationale d'administration à
l'ena la
partie d'enseignement consacré à la
défense aux questions militaires étaient
voisines de zéro et coisy mans rien mais
rien bon le alors vous dirais
heureusement l'ena va être supprimée
bientôt donc en ça peut changer avec le
nouveau service celui commission spu
avec mur ouais
bon voilà mais mais mais
mais si vous voulez alors il ya des
choses qui bougent un peu bas sciences
po par exemple moi quand j'étais jeune
il y avait il y avait aucun enseignement
sur sur les questions de défense et mais
rien bon maintenant on a créé un peu un
peu créé quelques quelques
quelques cours vont il ya des portes
quelques autres qui qui participe on m'a
proposé une époque de prendre en cours à
sciences po je n'ai pas voulu le faire
parce que j'étais trop paresseux mais
mais le bébé donc il ya un début de
quelque chose mais on est vraiment au
début il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup de
méfiance à désarmer question
internet temps et je mets juste une
petite note pour moi qu'il faut qu'on
parle de ça moi que je vous relâche
question internet arrive-t-il à garder
du respect pour la fonction
présidentielle le chef des armées après
avoir vu faire le guignol avec des
youtuber dont je reformule est ce que
vous arrivez à fait à garder du respect
pour le président macron quand ils vous
le voyez faire le guignol avec de
youtube heures et oui père à paris il va
être obligé d'afficher le portrait des
de youtube heures le 14 juillet c'est
quand ils vaste blague sainson déconner
alors si vous voulez général
sur tourner trois fois dans sa tombe
en général c est à mon avis à mon avis
depuis depuis sa mort c'est en 70 je
crois il passe son temps à se retourner
de manière voir dans donc donc laissons
laissons le en paix mais mes deux
remarques là dessus la première moi je
crois comme comme comme nos amis je
crois que il est important de sacraliser
la fonction présidentielle
moi j'ai été très frappé par le fait que
à leur manière les deux présidents que
j'ai côtoyés mitterrand et chirac avait
réussi à conserver cette
ce minimum de distance que doit avoir le
le président de la république par
rapport à la fois aux événements et même
quelquefois par rapport à leur
conseiller par rapport au point haut par
rapport aux alors
cent de leurs interlocuteurs sacraliser
le président oui c'est important et ça
compte pour les armes et que le
président se sacralise et bien sûr
maintenant quand on est chef militaire à
ce niveau là qu'on soit l'état major
particulier du président au conseil chef
d'état major des armées on
est focalisé exclusivement
sur la politique extérieure de la france
et la défense de la france la sécurité
et les français géraient le reste on
en fait abstraction et il faut en faire
abstraction parce
que parce que sinon je
veux dire on rentre dans le rang dans
les jeux politiques et non militaires on
peut pas faire ça nous ce qui nous
importe c'est que la politique
extérieure de la france la politique de
défense et de sécurité nationale soit
quelque
chose à quoi on puisse croire il est
dans son dans ce domaine là on ait
confiance dans le président voilà et le
est aujourd'hui honnêtement je vois pas
pourquoi dans ce domaine de la politique
extérieure et de la politique de défense
de la france on ne ferait pas confiance
au président macron objectivement je
veux dire depuis qu'il est là il a
largement repris une politique
extérieure gaullienne d'une part et
d'autre part il
a
comment dirais-je ont remonté le budget
de la défense qui était arrivé à un
étiage extrêmement bas et qui permet
aujourd'hui à nos armées de continuer
bon an mal an à se moderniser comment on
en parlait tout à l'heure vous
trouve très gentil quand même on
pourrait on pourrait mettre un peu de
poivre et de sel sur cette analyse mais
on peut toujours mais je veux dire j'ai
venait me chercher là où qu ils viennent
me trouver où le responsable c'est moi
avec la ferme et nahla c'était quoi ce
mais c'était quoi oui c'est quelqu'un
qui ne connaît pas la france bon
maintenant il fait des tournées dans nos
campagnes pour apprendre à connaître la
france on dit pas un français venait me
chercher tout le monde le sait le
problème le problème de m
le problème de nos dirigeants
aujourd'hui le poème de diriger
aujourd'hui peut-on déconnecté quoi
c'est qui ils sont déconnectés j'ai même
pas ça je sais qu'ils sont davantage
dans la séduction que dans la décision
voilà peu discuté de ce culte et de
l'air chaud brand c'est de la fumée ou
faire de la subornation de vote ouais
cirque eu envie mais ces sept ans mais
on l'a remarqué on l'a remarqué cette
évolution qui n'est pas que française
depuis un bouton cirque là comme a fini
par prendre une place prédominante est
finalement peut-être plus de place que
l'action l'action
soeur du rêve vous connaissez salon wii
question internet bonjour mon général
que pensez-vous des interprètes afghans
que la france n'a pas su et n'accompagne
pas tard jules mann une trahison
française mais
malheureusement je suis malheureusement
je suis d'accord avec notre notre
interlocuteur malheureusement moi j'ai
connu effectivement beaucoup de ses
interprètes afghans quand
j'allais visiter nos troupes là-bas et
j'étais très touché par par le fait
qu'on ne les ait pas automatiquement et
systématiquement accueillie en france
bon
je sais qu'il ya des choses qui ont été
faites mais malgré tout on n'a pas fait
assez et on n'a pas fait assez vite
question
internet son analyse des combats entre
israël et hamas quelles sont les
capacités réelles du hamas comment
font-ils pour se réapprovisionner le
hamas est approvisionnée par l'iran tout
le monde le sait ils sont approvisionnés
en contrebande soit par soit par la mer
soit par soit par le par l'egypte bien
sûr mais mais ceux
des capacités réelles elles sont elles
ont quand même considérablement
augmentée chiron on l'a vu une pluie de
roquettes que tirées depuis la bande de
gaza comme on n'avait jamais vu jamais
jusqu'ici jamais et si les israéliens
n'avaient pas leur dôme de fer là comme
on dit leurs capacités antimissiles
les dégâts auraient été mais
considérable sur la population
israélienne donc donc malgré tout le
hamas mais le hamas a pris des grands
coups et la riposte d'israël a été a été
aussi ville aussi les journalistes aussi
ouais ouais bon donc donc équilibre des
forces si je puis dire aujourd'hui à mon
avis est rétabli mais mais on est à dire
le hamas a commence à voir une force
plus importante c'est ça ou israël
israël a les capacités de se protéger
pas bien compris votre voilà les deux et
deux mon général vous allez les deux
voilà que
pense-t-il du projet red team censé
anticiper les menaces futures vous savez
engager des auteurs de science fiction
pour pouvoir aider sur wii oui on a fait
ça à l' agence d'innovation de défense
moi je pense que tout est bon à prendre
dans ce domaine géré le pire pour des
planificateurs et dieu sait que dans les
armées ont planifié en permanence le
pire de tout c'est le nombre d'
imagination le alors moi je trouve ça
génial cancon ans quand on embauche
effectivement des auteurs de science
fiction à l'avancé l'innovation
de la défense je trouve ça génial je dis
pas que ce qui en sortira sera forcément
génial effectivement c'est pas sûr mais
mais en tout cas on aura ébranlé un
certain nombre de certitudes on aura
créé
des interrogations et à ses
interrogations on va s'efforcer
inévitablement derrière de répondre
d'une manière ou d'une autre voilà donc
moi je suis totalement partisans de sa
wii que des six noms mais je connais le
patron de l'agencé innovation défense et
qui j'en ai parlé
des serait son numéro avant de partir en
tout cas en tout cas cessé trouve ça
très très réconfortant qu'on puisse
sortir des routines qu'on puisse sortir
des des chemins trop tracé était temps
oui peut-être oui mais je suis moins
pessimiste que vous comme vous le savez
comment tant que facteur qui vous dit
que je suis pessimiste non vous êtes
pessimiste par rapport à nos armées non
non mais si miss quand j'entends dire
que l'on est obligé de cirer les pneus
des vab le 14 juillet parce que on va
des pneus tous pourris quand j'entends
que nos hélicoptères ne vole plus parce
qu'on a plus de pièces quand j'entends
tout ça et vous le savez oui c'est pas
être pessimiste c'est sortir les doigts
du cul on
est d'accord je ne suis pas pessimiste
en ce qui a trait au prêtre aîné nos
forces à voir des hélicoptères qui ne
volent pas oui à voir des militaires
être obligé de s'acheter leur propre
paquetage parce qu'ils ont des sacs à
dos tous pourris des chaussures tous
pourris il faut arrêter le délire
d'accord
mon général aux
questions on est d'accord on est
d'accord mais mais je veux dire avec
des nuances à dire bien entendu alors
question quels sont les pays jugés
hostiles les
pays jugés hostiles mais bon la france
la france aujourd'hui n'a pas de pays
jugés hostiles y
en a pas il ya des il ya des pays qui
nous pose problème si
les pays qui nous pose problème qui sont
pas nos ennemis déclarés la turquie par
exemple c'est clair la turquie y en a
quand même eu un accrochage en mer avec
la turquie qui a failli mal se terminer
bon le la
turquie oui la turquie nous pose de
vrais problèmes la russie nous en pause
à l'occasion mais mais mais je dirais
elle a réussi peut-être par ces hackers
sens particulier par sirat les pirates
ce cyber bon
la chine nous en pose aussi l occasion
par
ces opérations de renseignement bon
voilà clair ou ceyrac associe même chose
ces pirates et
la question migratoire
comment
nous nous trouvons réagir à toute cette
misère du monde cette mise et où il
manie terre alors
d'abord c'est pas nos troupes qui vont
réagir c'est la france c'est
aux troubles qui ont fait un ménage
aurait peut-être pas si elles en
reçoivent l'ordre dans
le bon sens du terme c'était récupérer
les erreurs politiques ouais c'est le
genre savent leur bon
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui que
l'évolution
climatique mais pas seulement
l'évolution climatique l'évolution
démographique de
l'afrique fait
que inévitablement
on aura des flux de migration beaucoup
plus considérables dans 20 ans
qu'aujourd'hui et qu'on aura beaucoup de
peine allez allez allez réguler bon
voilà il ya d'abord des solutions
évidemment politique économique des
négociations politiques des solutions
économiques pour aider au maintien de
ces de ces migrants dans leur pays
d'origine ou faut les y faire revenir si
on le peut le faire mais
il ya une fine et ensuite évidemment la
question d'empêcher l'immigration
illégale et empêcher l'immigration
illégale ca veut dire en priorité on le
sait le contrôle maritime le
contrôle maritime aujourd'hui est exercé
au nom de l'union européenne par frontex
pour
l'essentiel avec
des moyens qui sont toutes qui sont
clairement insuffisants i
lya je sais à l'union européenne des
projets d'augmentation considérable des
moyens de frontex à condition que qu'on
arrive à un système de commandement
d'organisation
et de commandement qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient plus opérationnels qu'aujourd'hui
question internet septembre 1986 au
tchad vous étiez en poste en 87 le 7
septembre 1987 que s'est-il passé avec
les corps les ordres du quai d'orsay 7
septembre 1987 ça me semble qu'à une
colle pour moi parce qu'en 1987 j'étais
pas au tchad à ce moment là j'étais
c'était en france ouais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec lequel or ces
noms
c'est une colle pour moi je suis désolé
mais là c'est vraiment une colle si on
parle de l'avion jaguar français qui a
été abattu c'est pas le quai d'orsay qui
est imputée là dedans 87
non
je peux pas je peux pas je peux pas
répondre à la question internet quelle
quelle est la décision la plus difficile
que vous ayez du prône dans votre
carrière
le la décision la plus difficile de
prises dans la carrière alors
j'ai pas eu n étant pas chef
d'entreprise je n'ai pas eu de décision
à prendre pour mettre des gens à la
porte je crois que ça c'est l'horreur
pour un chef d'entreprise et donc je me
félicite ne peut jamais avoir eu des
jamais avoir eu ce genre des mains
décision la plus difficile c'est
pas facile de répondre je
pense que les
décisions les plus difficiles que j'ai
eu à prendre quand je sais chef d'état
major en tout cas c'était les
décisions de
d'ouverture du feu pour un repos pour
non pas sur les manifestants ivoiriens
mais mais pour les intimes des tirs
d'intimidation pour les empêcher de
s'emparer de l'aéroport d'abidjan
alors qu'on était dans une dans
une catastrophe totale pour enfin dans
une impasse absolue pour pouvoir évacuer
leurs ressortissants s'il fallait
absolument que nous gardions contrôle de
du de
l'aéroport et le et évidemment on
pouvait pas laisser déferler 10000
20000 personnes sur les reports sinon
cette édition on pouvaient plus évacuer
les français il y avait quand même à
l'époque je la paye avait encore quinze
mille français à ce moment-là à abidjan
et qui étaient menacés directement
parlera par les milices et le et
donc j'ai donné l'ordre de faire tirer
sur les ponts qui
séparent et la lagune enfin qui sépare l
la zone de l'aéroport du centre-ville et
le
nos hélicoptères l'onf et l'ont très
bien fait d'ailleurs parce que ma
connaissance ya pas eu de victimes du
tout et sert à provoquer l'arrêt
immédiat de déferlement vers le mais
c'était quand même une décision très
difficile à prendre non plus que j'ai
été appelé par le général poncet
commander sur place qui
me demandait mon accord pour pour cette
intervention à 3 heures du matin et que
j'étais j'étais très vite très très tout
à fait réveillé c'est pas ça mais que
prendre une décision seule comme ça en
pleine nuit loin du théâtre d'opérations
sans pouvoir sans avoir le temps d'en
parler avec moi l'état major c'était
c'était pas évident voilà mes mais cette
décision là je n'ai jamais regretté
parce que je savais que si on le faisait
pas c'était plus une question internet
qu'il est son avis sur la période des
gilets jaunes on remet ça ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir avec mon métier pour
le coup en toute franchise faveur
des jeunes bon je suis vous répéter un
peu des banalités parce que parce que
c'est ce que j'ai lu par tous bien sûr
c'est
à dire cette distance qui s'est créée en
france entre entre les métropoles et est
ce qu'on appelle la ruralité de
l'ensemble des petites villes et des
territoires ruraux 7,7
c'est ce sentiment d'abandon qu'on
ressent quand on se promène dans un peu
dans la france de l'intérieur sentiment
d'abandon parce
que beaucoup de services se sont
éloignés parce que les écoles il ya des
écoles qui ferment parce que les
hôpitaux et des hôpitaux qui forme ça
donc on a l'impression d'une français de
vitesse voilà quand on vit en province
et donc que
le mouvement des idées zone a été
déclenchée par des mesures qui
paraissait évidente de ville paris comme
la réduction de commodités de la
limitation de vitesse par exemple ou où
les taxes
sur les sur les carburants et as
clairbone sur le carburant je veux dire
ça
montre pour
le non aujourd'hui
à cause de la mondialisation
certainement il
est beaucoup plus difficile de
gouverner de
paris que ce n'était le cas ya quelques
années pourquoi
pas simplement parce qu'on connaît de
moins en moins à paris dans une élite un
peu fermé de moins en moins la réalité
de ce que vivent les gens en province ça
je le crois bon alors maintenant les
solutions apportées sont naturellement
très complexe mais on ne peut pas ou
très difficilement de
gouverner que pour les grandes
métropoles question
internet est ce que l'otan ne correspond
plus aux nécessités de notre défense
comme disait de gaulle quand il nous a
fait sortir de commandement intégré en
1958 comment commente-il l'évolution des
livre blanc de la défense avec l'abandon
de la défense erga omnes c'est à dire
contre nous ce
sont des questions évidemment qui sont
extrêmement complexes est ce qu'il faut
est-ce
qu'il faut mettre une croix sur
l'alliance atlantique et l'otan qui
sombre armée parce
que la guerre froide est terminée parce
qu'il ya plus le blog est terminé il y
avait encore avait encore des b-52 qui
venait sur paris il ya pas très
longtemps là non nous
sommes enfin la guerre froide elle s'est
terminée à la chute du mur du berlin a
malgré tout cher et il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui
la guerre des deux blocs le bloc
occidental contre le bloc soviétique et
l'otan avaient été créés finalement pour
faire face à la menace soviétique et au
pacte de varsovie et est donc la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
l'otan sert en quelque sorte riment
encore à quelque chose et la vérité
c'est que aujourd'hui la majorité des
pays européens considèrent
que leur unique garanties de sécurité
c'est les états unis et les états unis
et 7,7 conviction
delà de la très grande majorité de nos
partenaires vient du fait que l'article
5 du traité de washington donc le traité
qui a créé l'otan prévoit que si un des
pays de l'otan est attaqué tous les
autres doivent se porter à son secours
voilà bien et donc qui compte sur la
garantie de sécurité américaine et d'un
autre côté l'otan remplit aussi à sa
nombre d'autres fonctions l'otan
est le lieu où nos troupes s'entraînent
ensemble est le lieu où sont définis
toutes les normes de munitions et
d'armements de munitions et donc qui
permettent à nos armées d'être
interopérables c'est d'agir ensemble
n'est pas l'otan sont des bols pas très
efficace par rapport à google mais bon
mais
en tout cas concrètement je veux dire
l'otan a une double fonction une
fonction de lien avec les états unis et
une fonction de nous préparer à agir
ensemble ici
ajoute une troisième fonction qui est
née des circonstances qui est que l'otan
est une alliance qui peut intervenir à
l'extérieur pour sur une côte quand un
conflit local par exemple ou une crise
menace nos intérêts de sécurité sis au
long de sa condition qu'on est allés en
afghanistan notamment bon voilà
alors le temps donc des fonctions qui
persiste malgré la fin de la guerre
froide
est-ce qu'on a eu raison ou pas de
réintégrer la
réintégrer
la comment dirais-je la structure
militaire de l'otan moi je pense que oui
honnêtement je pense que oui parce que
être un pied dedans et un pied dehors
comme on l'a été très longtemps sa
présenter des avantages politiques mais
c'est avec les inconvénients militaire
sérieux on s'en est rendu compte
notamment par la guerre du golfe la
première guerre du golfe ou
d'un seul coup on a découvert qu'on
était absolument incapable de travailler
que nos alliés parce qu'on avait tout
perdu tout abandonner on avait plus de
munitions de même calibre on avait on
savait plus les procédures on savait
plus travaillé que donc notre retour
dans l'organisation intégrée de l'otan
était logique et c'est logique
maintenant est-ce qu'il faut rester
prisonnier de l'otan certainement pas je
dirais c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons
et que je souhaite personnellement de
tout coeur que l'union européenne se
dote davantage de capacité d'agir
ensemble parce que dans beaucoup de cas
les
nos problèmes de sécurité sont pas les
mêmes que ceux des américains et donc
l'otan n'ira pas s'occuper de problèmes
de sécurité qui concerne que les
européens militions
internet l'opération rousse existe
t'elle l'opération
ruth rose ronces je ne connais pas ces
cv de mémoire je crois que c'est zemmour
qui disait qu'il y avait des militaires
qui se préparait à intervenir en
banlieue et le nom ces opérations ronces
alors c'est une légende c'est peu une
chasse et légende absolue merci à jouer
assure fâchent
moi je suis effaré par les par les
fantasmes pompe qu'on peut faire naître
partout il n'y a pas dans les arts mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de noyautage
par certains partis politiques ça c'est
faux et premièrement et deuxièmement le
l'intervention des armées dans les
banlieues se l'est dit tout à l'heure je
veux dire moi en tout cas je suis
totalement opposé cependant ce serait
une grave erreur et je ne pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui ça soit le moins du monde
envisagée par nos autorités politiques
que pense-t-il de la vente d'armes
avions chars fusil aux pays étrangers
alors que nos propres militaires
utilisent des véhicules de plus de 30
ans alors je vais vous dire si
on veut pouvoir équiper l'armée
française à des prix qui ne sera pas
exorbitant il faut qu'on produise dès
que notre industrie d'armement
produisent à une grande échelle et donc
si on n'exporte pas eh ben ça renchérit
le coût de nos armements voilà et on
aura encore moins on aura encore plus de
vieux armement parce qu'on pourra pas
les changer pas c'est trop cher donc je
le marché que représente l'armée
française est un trop petit marché pour
les industries d'armement donc il faut
qu'on exporte voilà maintenant qu'on
exporte l'exportation des armements ça
pose des problèmes d'autre nature des
problèmes de sécurité mais ça c'est très
verrouillé en france à travers le
processus d'exportation ce qu'on appelle
la sienne j'ai à une commission qui est
chargée de sa interministériel et on est
très attentif aux risques de sécurité
pour nous notamment ou pour nos alliés
que représente l'exploitation de
certains armements ce qui reste c'est
que évidemment quand on exporte des
armements on prend toujours le risque
que ces armements soient utilisés de
manière scandaleuse par ceux à qui on
les a vendues vous foncez à quel pays je
pense à rien ni à personne un diplomate
non pas du tout non je pense pas mais je
trouve désormais nerfs général c'était
très ennuyeux de vendre des armements à
des pays qui respectent pas ensuite les
conventions internationales
quand on quand tout vent de l'armement à
l'arabie saoudite alors
que l'arabie saoudite passe au mixeur
des journalistes dans leur propre
ambassade mais
ça c'est pas avec nous c'est pas avec
nos armements c'est vrai que votre
mixeur c'est ça non c'est pas avec nos
d'armement verser des affaires est
correct l'arabie saoudite bullguard
bombarde
en afrique oui c'est du bombardement de
défense joue
avec les mots c'est ça arrange des
français c'est quoi non non non je veux
dire ça
pose des questions voilà ça pose des
questions d'éthique politique d'éthique
personnelle je veux dire il
ya déjà un contrôle très étroit sur les
exportations d'armement en france est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin est-ce qu'il
faut se poser la question de savoir si
on peut vendre à des pays qui
éventuellement peut-être un jour
pourrait ou alors quand ils utilisent
nos armements d'une faction d'une façon
inacceptable
et est-ce qu'il faut aborder les gueules
ouais mais peut-être faut-il à ce
moment-là arrêté d'exporter vers ces
pays se dire beaucoup de questions se
posent c'est un mélange compliqué à la
fois d'intérêt économique de d'intérêt
politique et d'un
devoir moral voilà quand on exporte des
laboratoire p4 connaissez le laboratoire
p4 et bien sûr quand on experts des
laboratoires pk tu à l'arabie saoudite
ouais c'est
bien c'est pas bien c'est juste du
business et c'est quoi vous savez un
laboratoire p4 moi je ne sais pas si
vous en avez déjà dû visiter moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de le faire pk tu mets p3o ep
3 c'est pas très méchant son jeu se sont
jamais que des labos si rien d'autre et
oui c'est ce qui s'est dit ce n'est pas
ce qu'on y fait dedans qui compte
comprenez et c'est pas nous qui
fournissons les souches de
de microbes de virus etc le
on peut qu'un pays veuille poursuivre
des recherches notamment
pour éviter une pandémie par exemple ça
me paraît légitime si
on soupçonne ce pays de vouloir faire de
la guerre bactériologique
alors alors là c'est une folie absolue
d'exporter effectivement ce genre de ce
genre de labo voilà donc c'est une
question de denquête rigoureuse sur un
ce qui peut advenir de ces laboratoire
p3 p4 vous
inviter à 10 h au 10 mai ces quads ihedn
bien chaude et l institut des hautes
études de défense nationale s'est
inscrit chose qui a été créée en 1948
quand
on sait quand on s'est rendu compte que
la défense s'était pas seulement la
sphère des militaires dire que la
défense d'un pays c'était la
mobilisation de ressources dans tous les
domaines aussi
bien économiques que j'allais
dire de
relations internationales
de police de jouir que tous les domaines
pratiquement de la vie de la nation
étaient concernés par la défense et
quand on s'en est rendu compte on s'est
dit mais il faut absolument qu à un
moment important de leur carrière les
responsables militaires et les
responsables civils se rencontrent et
suivent ensemble une forme de séminaires
qui
leur permet d'une part de se connaître
et d'échanger et l'autre par après
éventuellement de garder des liens qui
leur permettront d'agir ensemble le
moment venu voilà c'est ça c'est de
regrouper des responsables civils
et militaires à un âge où ils sont pas
encore arrivées au sommet si vous voulez
et même des politiques qui viennent à
lionel des députés les sénateurs etc et
le riz du vernis pardon c'est pour se
donner un vernis noms sont des gens qui
sont réellement intéressés par la
défense en général peut-être qu'ils ont
envie après de devenir un jour mise la
défense dans serrières ou président de
la république mais en tout cas
réellement entraînement intéressés et c
est une aventure qui dure qui dure huit
mois 9 mois dis moi peut-être et pendant
laquelle on faire si on de voyage est on
est on est on conduit ensemble en écoute
à s'orne de conférences y ont conduit
ensemble un centre d'études et on va le
faire maintenant puisque liège sud est
elle est en train de se réformer
complètement on va le faire de plus en
plus en utilisant des systèmes de
simulation de wargame j'ai donc de
manière des choses de manière
extrêmement modernes qui permettent de
se mettre en situation d'une crise grave
en france et est d'essayer de jouer les
différents rôles le rôle que joueront
les militaires le rôle que j'aurai des
responsables civils et de différentes
natures à différents endroits voilà et
je sais c'est un cas il existe des
structures qui ressemble un peu à ça
dans tous les pays européens enfin les
grands pays européens et aux états unis
mais mais je
crois qu'en france c'est un système qui
est qui est extrêmement utile extrémités
ya très longtemps il y à shenzhen a
publié un rapport qui est fait du bruit
auprès de jospin qui était le rapport
cometa qui était un rapport qui
décrivait le fait que notre espace
aérien été violée par une technologie
qui s'apparenterait une technologie
venue d'ailleurs là on a vu récemment
l'armée américaine déclassifier des
vidéos de d'ovni
est-ce que vous en votre est pas vous
avez abordé le sujet que le président
chirac ou avec le premier ministre
lionel jospin
les ovnis non non j'ai moi j'ai surtout
connu avec à l'époque chirac jospin jeu
surtout connu le 11 septembre et toutes
ses conséquences c'est à dire en fait
notre principale crainte c'était pas des
ovni mais c'était des avions civils qui
vient va s'écraser contre la tour eiffel
ou je ne sais où je ne saisis ou les
centrales sur percy convient assez rafat
été hospitalisé oui ou sur percy il y
avait une solution à laquelle j'avais
pas pensé d'abord je suis un peu sourd
avec tous les coups de canon que j'ai
encaissé mais le une question que je ne
m'étais pas posé effectivement on aurait
pu imaginer un attentat suicide sur
bercy sur le ministère des finances et
je suis pas du tout que ce réseau lui
problèmes de la france mais je veux dire
mais en or hate mais on aurait quand
même touché un centre nerveux
fondamentale du pays
attention l ai pas donné des idées non
non je veux pas donner surtout pas
donner d'idées surtout pas je souhaite
évidemment pas du tout que ce genre de
choses puisse être imaginé mais
mais mais non
il ya toutes sortes de l'or les ovnis
moi je trouve que j'en ai jamais
rencontré personnellement j'en ai jamais
vu pour être honnête et j'ai pas eu
l'occasion d'être confronté à des
enquêtes
scientifiques conduites sur le sujet
plus les américains déclassifie ce type
de pièce c'est parce qu'ils ont peur
c'est parce que ils veulent faire passer
un message c'est parce que bosch
moi
je pencherais plutôt pour la deuxième
option sûre je pense qu'ils veulent
faire passer un message ils veulent
savez il ya quand même aux états unis
une
tendance au complotisme qui est qui est
extrêmement développé de la navy quand
même je
veux dire à la limite là bas enfin ces
souvenirs que j'ai gardé des deux ans
que j'ai passés là bas l'abba à limite
tout est possible et imaginable cas on
est donald trump ses seins par exemple
par exemple mais tout est possible
l'imaginaire hommes c'est vous qui aviez
déployer la défense aérienne sur meudon
quand yasser arafat était hospitalisé à
percy où
ils sont de tous et surtout et sans
doute je m'en souviens plus précisément
mais c'est probable vous savez la
défense aérienne c'est encore un truc un
peu à part
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
directement comment
dirais-je mise en est même si c'est sous
l'autorité du chef d'état-major des
armées ssa des procédures particulières
parce que c'est lié à l'aviation civile
donc c'est directement lié aux services
du premier ministre
donc c'est le premier ministre c'était
lionel jospin qui avait fait déployer la
défense aérienne alors si je lis entre
les lignes oui c'est ça voilà est
ce que on arrive à la fin notre
interview
est-ce que vous avez trois livres a
conseillé à notre communauté mise à part
le vôtre les ors de la république ça
trois
livres est conseillé alors
6e la littérature je leur dirai qu'il
faut absolument relire julien gracq
voilà
les deux plus beaux livres que j'ai que
j'ai jamais lui sûr sûr sûr la guerre la
guerre vécue avant tout comme une
attente la
tante de la catastrophe c'est le rivage
des syrtes et et un balcon en forêt si
un livre plus
récent a conseillé moi je
pense si on s'intéresse à la stratégie
du meilleur générale je pense que il
faut lire livre de vincent desportes
entrée
en stratégie qui était à mon avis une
très très bonne manière de concilier la
stratégie au sens large telle qu'elle
peut être conçue aussi bien par des
politiques par des déchets d'entreprise
par exemple et puis telle qu'elle est
conçue et vécue par des militaires voilà
autrement autrement je peux pas vous
conseiller de lire des romans policiers
moi je trouve ça extrêmement délassante
diatta entendez d'excellents romans
policiers alors là je pense que vous
avez déjà toutes les adresses par
ailleurs vous regardez quad et elie
jamais
je regarde jamais la télévision je suis
au laisse apparaître un a priori je n'ai
même pas un simplement que les dernières
années mes dernières années d'activité
j'avais
été tellement pris dans la journée dans
la soirée les week-ends que que je si je
regardais la télé je ne lisais plus avec
du renseignement de première main en
plus voilà
mais mais mais si vous voulez donc ça a
été un choix entre la télévision de la
lecture et le puis je me suis habitué en
fait en réalité à lire les questions
internet connaît-il les worgens de
l'armée américaine pour contrer
l'insurrection des jeunes américains je
les connais pas cela non j'ai connu
d'autres wargame américain mais de
combat classique si vous voulez il ya
d'ailleurs il ya d'ailleurs des
histoires très intéressantes par exemple
sais pas si on le sait mais le premier
wargame que les généraux américains ont
joué pour
étudier la théorie
qui avait été élaboré par johnson et
mcnamara pour
combattre le nord-vietnam le
premier wargame a montré l'échec complet
ces stratégies ce qui a été vérifiée
exactement comme dans comme dans les
conclusions du wargame ça a été vérifiée
quatre ans plus tard et ça c'est quand
même intéressant sa preuve c'est la
preuve que que qu'un voire game bien
conçu peut déjà donner des indications
sérieuses sur le sur les stratégies
choisies est-ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'intéressant qui va rester sur internet
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
et aux jeunes générations à bâtir les
générations de mes petits enfants voilà
hebinger leur dire qu'il faut qu'ils il
faut qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils aiment
mois ceux ci croit profondément moi j'ai
aimé ce métier passionnément le métier
militaire il n'y a pas que des bons
côtés et c'est terriblement exigeant
mais mais je les aimais passionnément le
moi
ce que j'aime chez les jeunes c'est la
passion et donc il faut qu'ils arrivent
à découvrir le plus vite possible ce
qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils valent et
passionné et ce qui va les guider toute
une vie comme vous par exemple voilà là
sur votre métier de deux producteurs et
d'animateurs de deux de télévision moi
je crois que c'est la seule chose qui
compte vraiment la passion général henri
bentégeat merci
[Musique]
e